stuff I just clicked go live on my
browser maybe that'll do something
right now I just pulled up pulled it up
on my phone and we are not live okay
well it's live now isn't it no yeah it's
not it's pulled up right now it's not
live I mean it's it
it's our background it shows live for me
yeah but
she's on yeah we're live I think he said
you have to do something yeah I know
hello
I'm waiting for oh people are saying
live okay live they're saying it uh
how's it going everybody I think we're
live now so uh here's what happened we
are we did the show at Turning Point USA
this is Tim cassiro by the way by the
way not to not the Charlie Kirk show
we were doing the show at Turning Point
USA's am America Fest it was really
really awesome and then we're here for
the rest of the week so they were giving
us Studio space and equipment to
continue our show otherwise what would
happen is we fly out for the weekend we
do the live show and then we have to uh
fly back the next day and we won't be
able to do the show if that was the case
so uh we're just doing it here and uh
we're on the set of the Charlie Kirk
show because the temporary Studio that
we ended up building for some reason the
very last minute the camera stopped
working that's why everyone's like are
you live there's not live they're not
live they're late they're late we all
just ran full speed over to Charlie's
studio and then just jumped in his
chairs so we're gonna talk about the
news today we have we actually have some
big news the FBI knew the hunter Biden
laptop story was real
and they lied to Big Tech they lied to
the media in what is definitively now
confirmed a psyop they knew the story
was real they knew that crackhead Hunter
Biden lost a laptop and they tried
making this narrative that was more like
oh you know maybe someone hacked the
data and then cloned the machine and
then planted it the computer shop which
is this ridiculous conspiracy as opposed
to the more simple Narrative of you know
the poor guy is a drug addict and he
lost a laptop it happens so we got that
we have Stanford who released a guide on
what is it dangerous language hateful
language uh you know uh standard
language that is not uh you know
American
right they're saying that it's that's
hurtful to use the word uh American and
then we we have a bunch of other stories
too we'll just we'll get into a lot of
stuff harmful language
and then we have this viral post on
Twitter where I'm just gonna say I'm
sorry guys it's not family friendly but
there's a new version of The Pride flag
which has a puckered anus on it I mean
that's what everyone's saying I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna try and sugarcoat it
because you know whatever but they said
it's a red umbrella to symbolize sex
work so we'll talk about that before we
get started my friends please head over
to timcast.com become a member in order
to support our work directly as a member
you're not just supporting this show
you're not just getting a product you're
helping us build out uh everything we're
trying to do in order to change the
culture so we've I've long talked about
the coffee shops we're gonna be building
I'm really really excited for that so
thank you all uh for hanging out smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends joining us tonight we have a
couple guests we have Vivek ramaswamy
how you doing man I'm great introduce
yourself good sir yeah I'm Vivek I had a
career in biotech I built a biotech
company I was an investor and then I
hung the Jersey on that a couple of
years ago to start critiquing what uh
what I wouldn't call a biological cancer
but a cultural cancer that threatened to
infect both politics and business and
ever since then I've been on a mission
to hopefully save American capitalism
from politics and to save American
politics from American capitalism oh
that's so that's kind of the goal and I
wrote a couple of books about it and now
run another business thank you woke Inc
uh we definitely talked about this back
when it came out or or something
happened where maybe not when it came
out but I remember we were talking about
last year they're both pretty recent
yeah yeah and we were talking about your
work and stuff so I'm glad to have you
on this is going to be fun thanks join
us we also have Lauren Chen that welcome
back great to be back the last time I
was supposed to be on the show I had to
cancel because I had my baby so uh
clearly not in danger of delivering any
babies right now so it feels good to
well you have a baby congratulations
thank you and I guess if people don't
know me my name's Lauren uh happy to
call myself a TP USA contributor so we
just had America Fest it was awesome you
can find me on YouTube Lauren Chen is my
political Channel media Hall like is my
uh I guess my pop culture commentary
Channel I don't have books although the
Miami Herald did once refer to me as a
social media influencer and a hit piece
pretty big deal uh but you know if
anyone wants to support you can head on
over to etsy.com shop slash clearly pure
Naturals because uh we we kind of do
soap as our everyone does coffee we do
soap and that's totally pure natural
c-l-e-a-r-l-y-p-u-r-naturals.com uh it's
a product that doesn't hate you for who
you are and you know we are all about
that parallel economy awesome well
thanks for joining us should be fun we
got Luke of course he's here hey guys
last night was uh really fun it was
pretty incredible being off to being
able to feed off the crowd and it was
interesting seeing the TP USA crowd also
cheer for uh the larger ideas that I was
kind of spreading on there which was
pretty interesting
um Ian also you know fell off stage last
night he's not here he's recovering uh
we hope he is going to be doing well uh
Ian we're rooting for you
anyway uh today I'm wearing a shirt uh
depicting Bill Gates in his natural
habitat helping and saving Humanity from
itself and overpopulation if you like
this shirt you could support me by
getting it on thebestpoliticalshirts.com
because you do that's why I'm here Ian
we're rooting for you hopefully uh Ian's
okay you know I think he's been he
thinks he's been in a coma since that
since that fall it was a big fall it was
a big stage no Ian's actually completely
fine I was going to say there are so
many people who are so worried about Ian
right now he he was so he didn't realize
the stage was split with like a central
platform and then it branches to the
left so when he was on the front of the
stage he waved everybody and then spun
around and walked right into the pit and
just flopped like five feet to the
ground and then he jumped up and was
like I'm okay he's totally fine he's
totally fine uh you know he's just
chilling in the other room I guess so
there's there's someone in there pushing
buttons I can't tell it's like it's like
a one-way mirror or whatever anyway
let's talk about the news the big story
right now we'll jump right into it is we
have this from The Daily Mail
this is a psyop run by the FBI on the
American people Twitter files author
Michael schellenberger says FBI new
Hunter laptop was real but still told
Twitter and the U.S public it was fake
ultimately what we ended up seeing from
the latest Twitter files is that not
only was the FBI paying Twitter money so
that they could run censorship
operations but that Joel Roth I believe
it was yellow Roth wrote an email saying
basically what happened it seems that
someone download hacked into Hunter's
laptop downloaded the contents cloned
the machine and then dropped it off at
this computer repair shop in a in a
Russian disinformation campaign or
something I love I love that narrative
because it is the most insane conspiracy
theory I've ever heard and they call us
the conspiracy theorists for saying that
the FBI was was running a Psy up and
manipulating the elect you know
interfinging the election and all that
stuff but now here we are with
definitive proof because Elon Musk
bought Twitter and released all this
stuff we now know the FBI knew the story
was real live the big Tech lied to us
and I guess definitively interfered in
the election
well I think it's it's kind of hard when
they call the story disinformation even
from what Joel Roth was saying is that
if it was cloned and then put on a new
device and then left somewhere that
would still have meant that the
information was real I heard leftists at
the time saying no this is completely
fake it's not even real information so
we had so many different narratives all
of which were leading to it's not real
don't worry about it and I'm just
wondering is the FBI or individuals
within the FBI are they ever going to be
held accountable because at this point
since Trump we saw that they were
essentially acting like this pseudo
fourth arm of government doing whatever
they wanted trying to interfere with
American politics when does the
accountability happen
when an accountability happened
it's a good point a depressing point but
yeah I think we gotta stop calling it by
the way big Tech censorship I've been
saying this for a long time it is
government Tech censorship which is to
say it is just government censorship
disguised in the veneer of private
sector activity I wrote an up in the
Wall Street Journal when in January
about two years ago January 2021 and at
that time with far less evidence to me
it was already obvious right this was
the government doing through the back
door what they couldn't get done through
the front door under the Constitution to
me if you see the pieces already put on
the chess board you've got threats
already being issued you've got
inducements already being issued and
this isn't just inducements by the FBI
or the administrative class this is
hardwired in the law right not a lot of
people know this you have a section 230
section 2 literally says okay if it is
constitutionally protected content you
can still take it down and not be liable
under state law and by the way if you
want to actually be a extra cherry on
top we're going to threaten you that
we're going to break you up we're going
to you know regulate you call you know
quality call for your breakup or
whatever it is and so why is it
surprising that the exec the executive
branch of the government is just
executing on the threats that they made
starting two years ago so we need to
stop being surprised by this and just
recognize it for what it is this isn't
some sort of collusion it's just the
reality of directed government
censorship the only difference is
Vladimir Putin will tell you through the
front door that he's actually saying
what can and can't be said on the
internet here we abide by a fiction that
says that none of these are actually
just private companies that we're going
to have do it instead but it's the same
side of the story on two different sides
of Atlanta it's an illusion it's a lie
it's it's partly a bigger psyop that I
think finally is being exposed here
because you know you've been saying it
I've been saying it since 2008 to 2009
saying hey you know the intelligence
agencies have a lot of control over the
corporate media it's only a matter of
time until they have their influence
with social media and I think throughout
the last few years we have seen them act
in very coordinated ways we have seen
all the companies on the a dime turn and
make the same decision at one time
that's not an accident it didn't happen
because they all decided to come
together and do what's not good for them
destroy their business destroy the
ability of what made them great and
that's people being able to debate and
to talk to each other they went against
their own principles their own things
that were good for them and then obeyed
the government because as you said the
government was threatening them from the
very beginning and it's it's only
because they were there calling the
shots why we can't have free speech
online and to be clear this is not a new
phenomenon I mean even back when we had
print journalism or just televised
journalism I mean we had people like
Anderson Cooper have essentially been to
Fed Camp right so essentially all they
did was pivot to traditional media to
digital media so I mean as shocked as
well we shouldn't be shocked like you
said we saw the signs but as surprised
as some people are this is go this goes
back even even further than a lot of
people especially when it comes to the
church commissions and when we found out
that the CIA had officials at the top
branches of all the corporate media
outlets and Mr Vanderbilt Anderson
Cooper as some people call him you know
also trained to be a cie agent
coincidentally I had a couple
conversations with him about that uh
three times uh he didn't like me
bringing I was there yeah it looked like
runs up to Anderson Cooper and he's like
what did you ask him why did you leave
the CIA or something like that I was
like can you tell us about your training
at the CIA what happened here and and
what about that saying you know once
your CIA your oacia can we discuss the
influence of the Intel agency's leaking
fake stories to the corporate media that
always regurgitates them and whether
it's the wmds the banker bailouts they
are in lockstep and Barrel when it comes
to pushing out the bigger lies of of
course the government of the Intel
communities they've always been doing it
and we have always been sold a bag of
goods that were lies based off a bigger
agenda that they've been pushing I've
heard that I've heard activists call
Facebook face CIA book face CIA book
that book is also a good one and we were
talking about this yesterday on the show
that I think was Bannon mentioning that
these these these organizations these
big Tech they were built with government
subsidy and assistance and they intended
to use it in this way so I'm wondering
for you Vivek or whatever you guys
thoughts are like do you think the
Inception of these things when you
mentioned that section 230 has that that
provision section two I think you said
it was that allows them to remove
constitutionally protected speech do you
think that these things were built in
mind to do an end run around the
Constitution
yeah so I don't
to have the facts of them actually
having been in the same room with the
same venture capital investment on the
cap table of the company for the entire
conspiracy to still hold intact okay it
was saw at least softly designed that
way okay so this is actually I just want
to go into that into the specifics of
this law a little bit because people
actually mix up the two parts of section
230 all the time there's the part that
everybody knows which is that okay these
platforms aren't liable for what does
and doesn't show up that's section 230
C1 section 230 C2 is probably one of the
most remarkable statutes that most
Americans are not aware of which
specifically was a statutory workaround
for the Constitution so never never have
I seen a statute where do you say that
there's no liability for taking down
such material whether or not such
material is constitutionally protected
it was explicitly designed to allow the
government the federal government to
protect private companies to take down
content that the other the federal
government otherwise could couldn't take
down so I think that in a certain sense
the traps were already laid to say that
the federal government wants to make
sure it has the latitude to take down
content that the First Amendment
otherwise would protect it needed to
induce private companies to do it and
there's a great there's a great example
you'll actually like this one uh you
know relating to an issue that doesn't
relate to free speech where the federal
government want to do the same thing
with the War on Drugs okay so they
wanted to say okay we want to get drugs
off the street we're in a war on drugs
but we can't directly search passengers
on railroads or whatever directly so
what did they do they passed a law that
said that any Railroad Company private
company is immunized from liability they
can't be sued if the railroad company
searches the passengers on board for
drugs we're not doing it it's just a
private company doing it so guess what
now thankfully we have a supreme court
in this country which is the one branch
of government that I think we can still
at least if we're gonna have to pick one
that has its Integrity still intact it's
the judicial system said that not so
fast if you're going to use a federal
law to do through the the back door what
the government couldn't do through the
front door because of the fourth
amendment in this case that's still
State action and we're going to treat it
as such right and so the railroad
companies are bound by the Fourth
Amendment that's effectively what's
going on with these technology companies
so whether or not it was a you know
certain of these companies palantir and
others were definitely funded by the
government at Inception others may not
have been directly funded but that
detail matters less than the truth of
what comes out of it is functionally
these may as well may as well have been
arms of the government that's what we're
learning the latest story uh today is
that we're finding out that the FBI was
giving Twitter 3.4 million dollars as a
thank you for allowing them to of course
spy and kind of manipulate the whole
platform uh that's chump change that's
not a lot of money when we're talking
about these big companies but when you
look at the start of a lot of them
especially Facebook with nqutel when you
look at the grants that were given to
alphabet and Google when you look at the
government research and data especially
when it came to satellite imagery that
was given to Google Maps they were able
to have an advantage that no one else in
the market was able to have because of
their connections to government and I I
think they took an oath saying hey we're
going to be serving the government we're
going to be doing everything the
government wants if the government gives
us all these tax incentives all these
grad grants all this information and I
think that's the deal that they made
with the devil to destroy any kind of
legitimate competition making them the
current monopolies that they are now who
are kind of undefeatable you'll get
alphabet you look at Google who's going
to be competing them in the market we
can't compete with them because of the
unfair advantage that the government
gave them from the beginning
right so the question is what do we do
now right I mean I I've seen people say
oh well in order to break them up that
in and of itself is just more government
intervention so what's the answer going
take away all their taxes and stuff take
away all their grants get all their
money back
um that would be a start for me from my
point of view but more essentially
spread awareness make people aware like
hey your tax dollar is paid for this
let's get all that tax money back let's
let's also allow the free market to
speak let's also try to allow
competitors to be out there let's also
not intervene and regulate the market so
much as it is to make it almost
impossible for anyone because the the
person that loves regulations the most
is usually the head of Industries who
get to use it in order to destroy their
competitors right so I I agree with a
lot of that but the thing is we've seen
what big Tech does to its competitors so
even if we say all right you have no
more tax breaks none of these leg up
policies the government has been giving
you or what do we do when all these
servers decide to kick off a free speech
platform right because we see that
they're already big enough they're able
to act as a cartel yeah and they do I
think there's like a state action
Doctrine okay if it's state action in
Disguise the Constitution still applies
there's a First Amendment in this
country it's a really pesky thing that
says that if you're the government it's
an inconvenience you can't tell people
what you can and can't say so what's the
government doing they found a workaround
take Alex Berenson case or whatever by
the way I love this example because it
is literally what the founding fathers
would roll over in their graves if they
actually knew what was going on where
the first amendment is designed to do
one thing it is to allow citizens to
criticize the government so you take a
government critic what the government
does is they want to silence government
critics they can't do it directly so
they call any officials from Twitter and
say that here here's this individual by
name Alex Berenson in this case whatever
it doesn't matter who it is
why aren't you taking him down why
aren't you censoring him we know from
their private slack message channels
internally at the company that they felt
that pressure and they did it well guess
what it's a really simple solution if
you are working hand in glove with the
government if you are protected by
section 230 C2 which you can make an
opt-in statute if you're responding to
threats then you're bound by the same
standards as the federal government full
stop these companies ought to be bound
by the First Amendment full stop but
it's not just I just want to go back to
the hunter Biden story just to connect
this all together let me address this
put a pin in it the we've seen lawsuits
the judges don't care
so I actually think that um so so I
don't think all of these cases have been
argued nearly as well as they should
some have been argued in the ninth
circuit which is out in California when
you see these cases brought in the fifth
circuit okay which I think the judges in
the Appellate circuit the fifth circuit
I I'd like to see judge ho in the fifth
circuit take one of these cases Clarence
Thomas has already sent smoke signals
saying that actually this is a viable
Theory all the way up to including the
Supreme Court actually potentially
hearing these cases so I don't think
it's actually been tested in the right
way yet and the facts just keep getting
better and better I mean right the the
whole reason why these cases fail is
what is the Nexus of control that the
government exercises some of the ones
that have been brought have been super
you know on the weaker side where it's
some state that made a request and then
the company complied that wouldn't be
the case I would bring all right pick
the case where there's White House
officials that specifically call in the
company specifically name a specific
critic individual critic by first and
last name tell them to censor then you
have the evidence of the company
officials going back and forth saying
that they felt that pressure now you've
got the payments no better into
inducement than money to get a private
party to do what you want them to do
then you combine them with the threats
and now it's not just some Health
Department it's the FBI the guys who
wield the guns that's a stronger case
and so I think that you know we got a
lot of people got over eager before the
evidence actually presented itself I
think that picture's already changed and
I want to add to your point it's not
just picking out individuals and
censoring them they got so drunk on
power they have orchestrated a vast
censorship operation false flag with the
hunter Biden laptop story that literally
the laptop they knew they had it in
their possessions December 9 2019 when
they had it they knew it implicated Joe
Biden it made him look bad they knew an
election was coming up so they lied
about it they called it a Russian Hack
they orchestrated a vast conspiracy in
order to get the media because they knew
Rudy Giuliani was getting that laptop
too they knew it was coming out so they
orchestrated a psyop in order to of
course make sure that the story was Dead
on Arrival and then when it came out it
was censored everywhere and as we know
it also impacted the election very very
severely with many people believing that
it helped Joe Biden win the presidency
according to many polls out there that
right there is going to talk about that
and you can't even talk about that
exactly and major news organizations the
New York Post one of the biggest
newspapers one of the longest running
newspapers in the history of America was
censored wasn't allowed a voice was
taken off social media platforms was
taken off public Landscapes or even
being able to discuss what happened here
that right there is far more of an
atrocious criminal act in my opinion
than just picking out individuals and
censoring them did you see the news on
Kerry Lake today Vivek I did not see it
no so she uh her election contest is
going to trial there are two main
accounts two out of the ten it was a
chain of custody and I think do you
remember what the other one was
something to do with the counts but yeah
the the one was chain of custody being
broken and I forget what the other one
was I forgot the other one but the uh I
bring this up because we were just
talking about big Tech censorship the
FBI's government Tech censorship
government tax censorship you're right
and one of the counts that Carrie like
brought forward that was dismissed was
first amendment because we saw that
Democrats in Arizona I believe it was
Democrats you got what yeah illegal
tabulator configuration that's right so
I think what they argued was that
individuals in government well put it
that way had made contact with social
media to suppress certain individuals
and that was a First Amendment violation
and thus intentional interference or
misconduct in the election the judge
said no that count is dismissed you know
because my view of this is that
yes we can we can see that the hunter
Biden laptop Story the FBI's
manipulation did interfere with the
election absolutely we're seeing poll
after poll now show Regular People
saying if we had known about this story
if we knew it was real we would not have
supported this man for president and
it's substantial enough that some people
are saying if this story wasn't
suppressed many people would have voted
for Trump instead we could uh we could
have seen a different outcome in this
election
with Kerry Lake the judge outright said
well censorship no idea how do we
calculate votes based on that well
that's that's kind of kind of ridiculous
because actually if you look at election
law federal election law you you can't
do certain things as a campaign
regarding social media advertising right
because they see it as a violation so it
doesn't make sense to me that if you're
a candidate you can't spend however much
you want on maybe social media ads but
then social media doing whatever it
wants to censor different things well
that's totally okay right either we
acknowledge the fact that yes social
media and these advertising campaigns
they can sway people's votes and
therefore we need to control how much
candidates spend into it and do all
these work around the super Pacs or we
let social media companies do whatever
they want because oh I mean we can't
really decide how much uh posts might
inter interfere with voting right you
can't have it both ways right well I I
think the issue is we look at polls and
we say x percent of people may have
voted another Direction but how do you
actually quantify the impact of these
psyops of this government Tech
manipulation yeah so look I think that
there's you know three layers of legal
issues your issue is a pretty
interesting one one of the
Constitutional issues okay if you're
going to work around using the First
Amendment guess what the same
instruments that you use including
companies ought to be bound by the First
Amendment we talked about that already
second is actually I think there's a
strong campaign Finance case here there
is no greater Financial contribution
that Twitter could have made to the
Biden campaign than to have censored the
most damning piece of information on the
eve of the election that is a
constructive campaign contribution okay
so that's that's another legal layer of
federal laws then there's the state laws
of just old school people forget this
one Consumer Fraud all right you don't
know the definition of Consumer Fraud is
telling consumers you are doing one
thing such as not censoring speech or
Shadow bending or whatever when in fact
you are doing the exact opposite thing
like SBF FTX all that news but this
that's outside the political context
right so let's talk about that telling
customers that you're not co-mingling
funds when in fact you are co-mingling
funds that is definitional Consumer
Fraud that's not that different than
what was happening on Twitter telling
consumers actively through public
statements and otherwise we're not
engaged in viewpoint-based censorship
we're not engaged in Shadow Banning when
in fact your engagement Viewpoint bases
and Shadow banning all of which is
against the backdrop of forget the legal
issues is this the kind of society we
want to be living in irrespective of
whether or not it was legal that there
are centralized forces both in
government and in the Deep corporate
apparatus of the private sector that are
working hand in hand to suppress the
will of the everyday citizen the
question you asked was where's
accountability though okay and and I I
have a very very clear view on this
this systems of accountability include
the very same little three-letter
acronymous soup that's responsible and
infested in the first place it actually
starts with
who sits in the Oval Office the next
cycle around and by the way equivalent
for State Governors across this country
we need a government where the people
who report to the chief executive can be
fired by that chief executive this is
why I'm shocked this is not at the top
of a GOP agenda reforming these Civil
Service protection statutes that say if
you work for somebody you are eligible
to be fired by that person I've actually
so one of my big one of our successful
chapters of my biotech Journey was
actually by doing business in Japan we
did a three billion dollar deal at the
end of 2019 I spent countless days that
year in Japan and the funny thing in
Japan it's true in Japanese Pharma it's
true in almost Japanese corporate
Japanese corporate is that even if
you're the CEO of the company you can't
actually fire the guy who's the head of
your research division or the head of
your commercial division turns out that
that means if the CEO says this is the
direction that the company's going if
the guy who's running research doesn't
agree with you he's going to keep doing
whatever project he was working on
before anyway because if you can't be
fired it means you don't really work for
the person who you elected who was put
in that position so that's in the
corporate context it's not any different
in the governmental context we need to
make sure that the people who we elect
to run the government
are the people who run the government
and I personally think this is one of my
big disappointments in Donald Trump is
that you have a guy who will complain
and identify the problem in a lot of
ways but we'll complain about Anthony
fauci will complain about James Comey
doesn't fire them when the thing you got
to do is very simple yeah you fire them
you fire the legions of people who work
for them you fire the managerial
industrial complex underneath and around
them that is accountability because
otherwise any legal battle isn't going
to sort this out that is what draining
the swamp looks like and that's what
it's going to take place you should have
done that but I I don't mean this to be
a defense for him because he should have
done it regardless but anytime he would
make these staff changes the media would
of course paint it as him trying to
ensure that individuals pledged loyalty
to Trump that he was some kind of
fascist dictator when really I don't
think it's too much to ask that if you
work for a president you should be on
board with the president's agenda but
that was absolutely how the left was
spinning things anytime did Trump did
make staff changes but then he just
turns the media into fourth branch of
government that he's reporting to yeah
they were saying that anyway right now
that's what he did they were saying he
was a fascist anyway so there was no
reason for him to capitulate I think he
loved the media too much and tried to
appease the media way too much because a
lot of these policy shifts especially
with the DHS happened under his watch it
was also him that approved gain of
function work in Wuhan China before this
whole entire debacle a few years ago it
was his administration that pushed a lot
of this stuff that now we're dealing
with that was turned against him as he
had the users he had people on his staff
saying hey they're going to censor you
hey they're censoring all of your top
supporters all the people who got you
elected all the people who worked so
hard on the internet spreading memes
talking about you they're all slowly
being eviscerated and that circle is
coming closer and closer to you he
ignored it Jared Kushner told him to
shut up and to just play ball he did and
then we're here
the executive order uh in regard to how
section 230 could be enforced
essentially saying that a platform would
have to pick between being a platform
and a publisher I thought it was a very
good executive order was really changing
the policy and we can go into them but
no one ended up challenging in court so
it was useless but I'm just talking
about running I'm just talking about
running an organization running a
government you run a company you know I
run a company people have run countries
whatever it is there's a simple
principle if you run the organization
you decide who works there and who
doesn't work there period and a good
litmus test of whether our leader is
doing it I don't care if it's a CEO of a
big company I don't care if it's if if
the chief executive of a country if you
are complaining to the media about the
people who work for you that means that
you have already failed because if you
had to as the leader of the Free World
complain to third parties who write
about you that means you already didn't
do your job because the people shouldn't
have been there in the first place I do
think the Civil Service protections need
to be repealed I do think that actually
you know what if you're president United
States you can't work for the federal
government for more than eight years I'm
not sure that the people who report to
the president of the United States
should be able to work for the federal
government for eight years actually I'm
sure they shouldn't but even still I
don't think you need to wait for
congress I think article two of the
Constitution says that those Civil
Service protections are basically
unconstitutional anyway if you run the
federal government then dog on it run
the federal government and whoever sits
in that office next that is not Joe
Biden whoever that might be I don't care
if it's a Democrat Democrat Republican
democrats should be every bit as bone
chilled by what happened as Republicans
the same demands are upset with what
James Comey did with what they see is
tilting the scales back in 2016. this is
not a Republican or Democrat issue it is
the fact that whoever we elect it might
even be the guy I want I don't care I'd
still rather the guy I didn't vote for
be the guy who runs the government
rather than actually have somebody else
who runs the government who temporarily
does what I want them to do when it was
actually somebody who nobody elected
that is account that is what
accountability looks like and I'm
surprised not enough Republicans right
now are even talking about that as a
solution it's probably going to be Biden
and fetterman with the way things are
going and let's be honest here
2024. they fortified the elections I I
don't see Republicans winning especially
when it comes to ballot harvesting
especially when it comes to all the
things that they have kind of enshrined
themselves with and I think the main
reason Democrats aren't doing anything
is because they're winning they're
they're the intelligence agencies are
using them right now and they're of
course benefiting greatly they're
getting all the seats in in the Congress
in the Senate they're getting the
presidency and most likely you will
still get the next presidency and
probably control politics for the next
few decades unless something drastically
changes which I don't see it drastically
changing well it's interesting if you
look at all the quote anti-establishment
leftists who traditionally would have
been against operation Nations covered
by the FBI against the American people
you would think that a psyop like this
would would upset them but what we see
is because the outcome happens to be one
that they favor and that it's censoring
their opposition they're silent right
because the the old song and dance used
to be oh it's a private company they can
do what they want now that it's been
revealed it's actually not just a
private company there's State
involvement now they're saying oh well
you shouldn't have the right to do that
spread quote unquote misinformation or
hate whatever they want to call it in
the first place so I mean what we see is
that people say that you know leftists
have double standards is actually one
very consistent standard if it helps me
it's good and so that's why we see so
many people who again like actual
progressives who should be anti-fbi
running cover for the swamp I don't mean
to get to like you know uh abstract here
but
here's a pattern I see in the moment we
live in in general okay people are
addicted to the drug you will give them
here here the drug is that you give the
the leftist here as you as you call it
is the outcome you want so we will
violate whatever procedural Norm we
clearly held near and dear to our heart
if we at least get to the place we want
to in the short run by the way that's
the same human into intuition that led
these social media companies to get as
powerful as they did you give something
away for free that's the other thing
people will flock to it people forget if
you get something for free that you're
the product yes you are not the consumer
you are the product but we have this
cultural moment we live in that as long
as you get that that it's like a little
hamster on the wheel as long as you get
that little jolt that serotonin surge
that that experience of satisfaction you
are willing to trade off the thing that
in your deeper Soul matter to you over
the long run be it your data be it your
privacy in the case of index funds I
mean this is what I spend my day job
your right to express yourself as a
shareholder in Corporate America giving
Index Fund away for free they'll say
fine I'll hand over my vote give you
know the idea that actually I care about
autonomy and individual procedural
Justice I'll give that away if you
actually put my guy in office we live in
this in this deeper cultural moment
where the everyday citizen is so effect
so weak-willed that we will trade off
the thing that we know we care deeply
about for some short-term outcome and
that's what the managerial class is
exploiting like I don't even see this as
a left and right issue it is a battle
between the managerial class the
bureaucrats who staff the middle layers
of for our universities to our
government to most large companies in
the private sector the managerial class
is able to give the masses what they
want like feeding cocaine to a drug
addict but because that drug addict is
willing to accept it the managerial
class is able to wield its power and I
just think that's the defining to me
it's less about left and right it's more
about this managerial technocracy and
bureaucracy versus the everyday citizen
because the everyday citizens inner
level of fortitude was so lacking that
they were able to be bribed into it in
one sphere of Our Lives from another
that's what I see happening you talked
about how you know Democrat and
Republicans should both be concerned
about this excuse me but I think what I
see with Democrats and Republicans is
all they want to do is the bare minimum
to maintain power to stay in office to
have a job they don't actually want to
do anything that could harm them so what
we see with Republicans is
throw the bare minimum out there for you
know the red meat to the base stay in
office say what you got to say the
Democrats of course have a more fervent
base with many of these younger leftists
so they're forced to actually try and
give them a little bit more even though
they don't want to I think if Democrats
Republicans had their way they'd sit
back and never say another word and just
keep getting their paychecks so so long
as you have on the left this uh I don't
know Zeal and energy then you're going
to keep seeing Democrats more in line
with this or as Luke put it the FBI is
using the Democrats they're winning
they're getting power they're in line
with it and then you have some
Republicans who are speaking up but it's
only some I guess my point on all that
is
it sure it should be a problem for
Democrats and Republicans but I don't
think they're actually there in the
fight or concerned about anything I mean
maybe there's like 10 members of
Congress who actually care yeah see I've
got a slightly different theory in the
Twitter files leak I think there
actually was maybe one Democrat
representative yeah that expressed
concern about it and I was actually kind
of impressed about how many world
leaders including the likes of Angela
Merkel I I think uh Express concerns for
the freedom of speech of course none of
them said anything publicly because we
can't seem to be citing uh publicly with
Donald Trump in any way even if it's
just defending uh freedom of speech but
I I was I don't want to say pleasantly
surprised but it was like oh okay yeah
there's that yeah I mean that's that's
part of the reason why I don't I mean
even Bernie Sanders has been actually
give this guy credit about whatever a
year year and a half ago was the first
person on the left to say that he did
not and nobody and nobody dislikes
Donald Trump more than Bernie Sanders
based on what he said but that he
doesn't want a fourth branch of
government in Silicon Valley deciding
who doesn't doesn't get to speak to the
American public and so is I don't I
think what you said is descriptively
true but I I would there's a lot of ways
you could a lot of lenses you could
bring to describe the same phenomenon I
bring a different lens which is that
it's not even the left wing and the
right wing lens I think what the left
does better today is that they feed
that generational hunger for a cause
like I told you all right we have this
vulnerability in an entire generation of
Americans to latch on to what someone
sells us that's the cocaine for the drug
addict well one one form of cocaine for
the drug addict is religion for a drug
addict who actually lacks religion in
the first place I mean the things that
used to fill the void of human purpose
right you could debate what it is right
patriotism Faith hard work family pick
your favorite fill in the blank whatever
they are they've disappeared in Modern
Life and I think what the left has done
effectively is at least to feed that
vacuum with picurism you know wokism
climatism covetism whatever the ism is
they've come up with modern secular
religions that fill that void and I
think that the right where where the
right is actually failing is what you
call the fervance I think that was the
word you use well the right could tap
into that fervance if we actually had an
affirmative alternative that can fill
that void of purpose and meaning and I
think instead we're myself included or
just taking you know playing a game of
whack-a-mole taking a jackhammer to one
form of poison at a time instead of
figuring out what is what is the
alternativism maybe it is americanism I
think it's a pretty good alternative let
me pull up this story because you
mentioned americanism and it's the
perfect time we have this from Fox News
Stanford releases guide to eliminate
harmful language cautions against
calling U.S citizens American Stanford's
index says it's a goal its goal is to
eliminate many forms of harmful language
so you said maybe the fervents or the
Zeal that the Reich could tap into is
americanism there's America first but uh
they're preempting you they're already
coming out and saying it's harmful
language to do so which is a good sign
that this is actually the direction
this way because the the things that
they've replaced religion with they are
actually Tools in which they gain more
power whether that's feminism radical
leftism wokism you name it these are
actually tools that not only replace
religion climatism exactly they
simultaneously further State Control
it's actually the opposite with the
right what are we trying to get people
passionate about small government
religion families being less subservient
to the government it's funny we're
actually shooting ourselves in the foot
by trying to breed this I guess fervance
in dependency and otherwise living
happily lives that don't require us to
become Servants of this state the
leftist is smart in that way they
understand that if you want people to
essentially need you you need to not
only make it their politics but also
their personal identity and religion as
well and I think that with the absence
of religion I I think a lot of people
replaced you know the Christian church
or the uh you know Islam with
specifically the state and they worship
fauci they have candles of them they
have you know altars of them so so I I
think at the end of the day the
Republicans need to be called out
because if they're good at anything it's
capitulating and surrendering Uh Kevin
McCarthy right now I don't see reigning
in the FBI he has an opportunity to do
so he's not but Trump is still endorsing
him Kevin McCarthy called for Donald
Trump to resigned as president of the
United States why are you endorsing him
and telling your local Congress members
not to fight his appointment this is
absolutely crazy
becomes the institutionalist that's just
that's not true politics said that the
number one priority for Republicans is
actually to ensure that Ukraine gets
those missiles and is able to defeat
Russia this says zelinski is coming to
the United States Capitol to address the
United States yes as there's going to be
a big Bill negotiating 46 billion
dollars that's going to be additionally
possibly sent to Ukraine to prolong this
larger proxy war which is bringing us
closer to the brink of nuclear Holocaust
you mentioned earlier in the show Luke
about how they're taking your tax money
and I was going to say something then
but I'll say it now too about this this
all the money that's sending to Ukraine
it's modern monetary policy they're not
they're not really taking your tax money
they're just Mass printing your money
and extracting through inflation from
your savings so whether whether it's
paid or not they're finding a way to gut
the the American middle class so they
can fund their Wars they could do
whatever they want there there's no
oversight it's a transfer of wealth from
from everybody else to the super rich
it's socialism for the super rich that
we're seeing right now with specifically
the military-industrial complex getting
their way we're running out of missiles
there's other countries that are running
out of bullets especially Germany there
was a news report saying Germany has has
given out so much money they're running
out okay this is one of those countries
that's not critically low exactly so you
want to go in this direction though
you're not getting a funny fact here
okay so
which is the country
which is the major developed country
that lobbied against the EU ban on
Russian oil imports anyone know the
answer to this
the United States
the Biden White House was the major
nation that was begging the EU as we now
head in the end of the year the Russian
the EU ban on Russian oil imports goes
into effect now why is that it's
actually there's a long reason why we've
gone to war on our own fossil fuels
industry that actually worries about the
consequences for Global you know let's
just say oil and gas markets if that EU
ban actually goes in especially when
Chinese coronavirus related restrictions
are being lifted there's a supply demand
shock but but I want to point out the
irony of this
we are with one hand sending 40 to 45
billion dollars or more to Ukraine to
fight against Vladimir Putin while with
the other hand are the leading nation
that calls for
overriding the EU pen on Russian royal
Imports which in turn finances Putin's
war machine to actually invade Ukraine
so that's why the whole thing is
actually even a farce the idea of
getting into should we or should we not
support Ukraine okay I think we're over
allocated to Ukraine we need to focus
our military's energy on the one
geopolitical threat that matters the
United States which is China but that's
a policy Point here's even if you were
committed to the pro-ukraine cause at
all cost
even the effectuation of that is itself
frustrated by the fact that if you
wanted to do it you would be starving
Putin's Army yet Biden is the one who's
actually arguing for allowing Putin's
Putin finances War Machine by selling
oil and gas to Europe which is actually
the laughable farce of the whole thing
and I believe it was also fertilizer as
well I think uh someone could actually
check me as well that they were also
buying a bunch of fertilizer from them
and financing them that way why is why
are we doing it why are we why are we
playing both sides on the issue
so it's because it's a cell form of
self-loathing actually I don't mean this
I don't mean this just in a culturally
superficial sense I mean in a
deep-seated sense we live in a moment of
Western and particularly American
self-loathing and it'll just since I've
been up the oil and gas example I could
give you six fears of life where this is
true but let's talk about the oil and
gas examples I just brought it up all
right why is it that now we're talking
about other religions let's talk about
climatism why is it that the members of
the Church of climate the climate
activists are
so averse to the United States producing
oil and gas but are perfectly fine with
global markets that allow the likes of
petrochina and also many Russian oil and
gas producers to pick up the slack
ironically oil and gas producers over
there who have actually methane leakage
that is far worse than in the Permian
Basin of Texas and by the way even if
you subscribe to The Climate religion
methane is 80 times worse for for the
global atmosphere and global warming
than is every unit of carbon dioxide why
are they okay with that the answer to
that question is the same as the answer
to the question of why those are the
exact same people who are also opposed
to the development of nuclear energy in
the United States which would actually
be the single most efficient form of
carbon-free energy production known to
mankind what's going on the problem
isn't that let's say nuclear energy
wouldn't be good enough at solving the
alleged climate crisis it is that it
would be too good at solving the alleged
climate crisis which in turn is really
just a vehicle for effectuating the
agenda of global Equity so you want to
they answer the question why Tim it is
because this is a a moment of global
redistribution back from the West to the
other side of the world including Russia
and China and everything in our
self-loathing is flogging ourselves for
the sins the perceived sins of the last
century to say that we could give the 45
billion to Ukraine but we also want to
make sure that actually we shift oil
production to places like Russia and we
don't ban the Russia EU ban and Russian
oil imports because it's really just a
form of self-loathing at its core that's
what we're seeing on display and just
really quick that's because war is a
racket and throughout history there have
been powerful people supporting both
sides that's been well documented but
with the United States supporting
Ukraine right now and giving them
billions of and billions and billions of
dollars there's this misnomer that it's
oh Ukraine's just doing whatever Ukraine
wants it's a Ukrainian policy but we not
only incentivize the continuation of
this proxy war which is extremely
dangerous but also at the same time we
have to remember when zelinski actually
reached the peace deal with Putin they
had a date where they were supposed to
come together sit down meet and
negotiate and sign up peace deal we had
Western Powers come to Ukraine
specifically the UK UK prime minister
came there and said no you're not
signing this peace deal and Ukraine has
been the one backing away from peace
continuing this war endangering everyone
which is absolutely insane as this war
is also hurting the poorest people in
the world not just the people of Ukraine
but this has global economic impacts
that's going to wreck our whole entire
Financial system in ways that we have
never seen before and I think it's right
to say that there for a lot of the
activist class there is absolutely
self-loathing involved especially when
it comes to the climate change agenda
but when it comes to Ukraine
specifically and yes even climate change
I also don't want to underestimate how
how many people are actually getting
rich off of this how many people are
getting rich off of the subsidies to
Green energy that no you're right it's
not as efficient as nuclear places like
France like we already know that if we
were to build new nuclear plants in the
U.S which I don't think has been done
since the 70s they would be even safer
than the ones that exist now but we
haven't been able to do it because of
fear-mongering same with Ukraine it's
bad for America it is very good very
lucrative for the military industrial
complex zielinski actually spoke at one
of these conferences for I guess big war
they're not even trying to hide it at
this whole point it's so blatant The
Exchange is happening there you
mentioned with climate change and it
reminded me of this viral video that
people keep sharing where it's this guy
saying if if all of this stuff was true
in every prospectus for a a for a
nuclear study oh for construction it
would say you know the condos in Miami
Beach in 30 to 40 years your investment
will be zero as the water rises and
makes us uninhabitable but not a single
Bank not a single person has ever
brought that up so why are they still
investing in why are they still buying
30 to 40 year you know Properties or
loans if the water is going to rise and
wipe out this whole area no they they're
living in the beachfront property so
that other people can't do it and you
know so they're safe and and they are
willing to take the bullet for all of us
by living bearing that cross exactly
brave men lots of beachfront property as
well Barack Obama lots of beaches
we want to thank these guys for their
sacrifice it really means a lot to us
thank you it's it's the meme of uh uh
you know from The Simpsons of the person
jumping in front of the bullet for Apu
or whatever you know they're they're
trying
yeah I love that you'll find a Bill
Gates story he was um so he was my
College commencement speaker and you
know what I was looking at that time he
was the world's richest man
I didn't come from a lot of money I was
unapologetically ready to make some
after I got out of college moving to New
York working to hedge fund I was like
all right let's let's figure out how one
creates the level of of wealth that Bill
Gates has the only thing he would talk
about is how to the whole speech it was
it was one of the more disappointing
speeches I heard my life remember it I
was I met him on stage afterwards
it was all about how to give back what
one has gained and I love and ever since
that moment I was like look the
expression of even giving back
doesn't make sense to me because it
assumes that one took in the first place
actually I think he's done a lot of
taking ever since he started the giving
back project but making the PC was not
actually the one thing that he took in
the first place that was actually the
one thing that he created and I think it
was right around then I mean this was
this is as I graduated from college in
2007 then came to 2008 financial crisis
right after right after I graduated and
that was when this period of of
apologism began and that's why I think
americanism for a different reason too
is part of the solution is once we stop
having to apologize for the successes of
the modern West for the successes of
modern America we can have a model that
the rest of the world can follow to lift
themselves up but I I could I could
almost pick 99 of the things that the
four of us at this table would find
disappointing about the direction of
modern American culture and pin it to
this culture of apologism for our own
success and I think that that's why the
answer can't be us going one at a time
playing whack-a-mole trying to send that
mole back into its into its rabbit hole
but to instead fill that void with the
sense of revive Pride an Unapologetic
pursuit of excellence and that is what
it means to be American I am not going
to apologize for it through some climate
religion that causes me to adopt an
emissions cap through some racial Equity
system that causes me to use a racial
quota system to hand out Goods According
to some Metric other than Merit no I'm
going to do this in the same way that
got us 250 years into this experiment I
am not going to apologize for it if
we're going to make another 250 years
from now that's how we're going to do it
and I think we need to get I wouldn't
use the word religious but I think we
need to get fanatical behind the idea
that set the whole experiment into
motion rather than hanging on and you
might disagree with me here but rather
than hanging on the thin uh siren song
of proceduralism right liberals abandon
liberalism because because they were
smart there's something about the idea
of just hey it's just about Free Speech
free markets hey individual autonomy
those are just procedural Norms that
don't satisfy the more base human hunger
in a way that wokeism or climatism or
covetism does and I think that I think
that the what the right needs to wake up
to in this country is that just falling
back on the slogans of liberalism
proceduralism is not going to be enough
we need our own affirmative values I
think Excellence the Unapologetic
pursuit of Excellence what I was just
talking about probably belongs on that
list maybe somebody else says it's
something else but we need we need an
affirmative
content that people can actually get
fanatical about but it's actually
content that's actually far more Rich
than what because on the other side let
me jump to the story we'll get to this
next subject here because uh talking
about americanism I think is uh a good
americanism is a good subject to segue
uh into this story for us to segue into
the story we have this from timcast.com
EU approves carbon tax for individuals
some officials warn the new CO2 taxes
could be politically suicidal and Spark
widespread protests under the EU
emissions trading system two
ets2 the new polluter pays taxes will be
imposed on buildings and for
transportation fuels as part of a plan
to reduce Europe's greenhouse gases by
55 percent compared to a 1990 to 1990
Levels by the year 2030. the carbon tax
will impact gas diesel heating fuels
like natural gas making it more
expensive for Europeans to travel and
Heat their homes now we saw when France
tried raising that petrol tax and then
they got the yellow jackets protest for
like two years I don't think this will
go over well but I will just stress to
everyone who is American if you do not
stand up for yourself and for what you
believe in this is coming here next well
there's actual conversations in the
European Union right now warning about a
yellow vest populist Uprising because of
how they're just bleeding the average
person there and I literally wrote
carbon tax because I was going to say
that next without even knowing that you
were pulling up the story because it was
already in my mind another thing I
wanted to bring up really quickly Bill
Gates also is an individual who promised
to give the majority of his wealth away
to charity he has since then doubled his
money it's not a coincidence because
he's launching a lot of scams and when
you look up the larger kind of uh
philanthropy scene when you when you
look at a lot of these people who say
that they give the most usually those
are the some of the most ruthless
Psychopathic business people that you
could ever imagine that are milking the
system abusing the system and this
larger climate change Ponzi scheme is
just a way to try to bleed out the
people take away more money for them and
to control them as a former as a proxy
social credit score system there's a
reason Airlines started calculating your
your carbon credit score how much carbon
are you using here there's a reason
private businesses and Banks started to
calculate this on their own initiatives
it wasn't their own initiatives it was
centrally controlled and centrally
pushed out there and this is the slow
creeping Chinese totalitarian Society
society that they're going to be
bringing in everywhere Europe is just
the beginning they're going to be
bringing here bringing it here to the
United States eventually Canada is Right
lock and step with Europe in Canada
they've actually floated is not being
implemented or anything like that but
actually capping the number of miles
that an individual may be able to travel
so essentially if you drive for work and
you want to go on vacation for summer
holidays well guess what you can't buy
that plane ticket you've already
exceeded your mile your mile quote and
they've even floated things like oh you
could have cap and trade for individual
miles and oh you have an electric
vehicle well now we can monitor who is
going where and driving what so they
might actually be able to just press a
button and stop your engine to ground
you so that you don't go anywhere this
is terrifying and it's being done in the
name of compassion and I think you know
what I I'm gonna say this if these
policies take hold anywhere it's not
going to be Europe it will be Canada let
me ask you do you think uh maybe 10 20
years you're driving in your Tesla and
then you get a carbon you know energy
consumption warning and it slows you
down and says return home you've
consumed too much energy yeah and it's
like you're at in the arcade if not
we're gonna have a central bank digital
currency that is deducted from your
account that is linked to your other
otherwise carbon emission footprint
unless you actually comply that that's
what we're heading there are people
trying to get that done for the Canadian
trucker protest already anyway electric
vehicles that were they were trying to
actually ground them uh make them unable
to move the state of California the
state of California literally told
people stop charging your electric
vehicles why because their power grid
was going down why because they're going
into this green energy Revolution which
is again a larger carbon tax a larger
social credit score but I'm glad you
mentioned California because because
here's how the global Cascade works on
any of these climatists or even you know
beyond climate policies Europe does
something bone-headed because they have
their own insecurity complexes
apologizing for their own colonialist
past or whatever is going on in Europe
California then copies that European
policy California then becomes
competitively disadvantaged relative to
other states but California which has
the largest pension fund system in the
country Calpers uses its money to get
BlackRock and State Street in Vanguard
to then Implement that through the
private sector for the rest of the
country so that is the same Cascade we
see that pattern time and again which is
why every American citizen should
absolutely pay attention to what is
happening in Western Europe because it's
going to find its way into the United
States by the government of California
which then runs through the money of
Calpers which then runs through the
money that streams into the private
sector of the United States that's just
the loop it's sort of the the unpaid the
the unidentified invisible Road of
social policy from Europe
China stuff like that because those as
ESG scores I mean people start to wonder
why is Disney going so woke when their
movies keep bombing well it's exactly
because of those investors that are
looking specifically for companies that
are pushing these and it's not for
financial gain because clearly these
companies aren't making money it is
actually an ideological push and I think
you're wrong if you believe that oh
money is the ultimate mover and maker
right now because there are people who
are willing to lose a lot of money in
order to push this agenda which is why
I'm also more optimistic on Market
Solutions than I am on Government
Solutions by the way do you guys I don't
know if you I don't know if we haven't
talked about the software but if you
know what strive when everyone would
strive or does that mean it's a little
bit yeah yeah so my whole view is
look so you're just for people who
aren't aware about what's going on with
the BlackRock problem all right you've
got three asset managers they manage
over 20 trillion dollars okay that's
BlackRock State Street Vanguard that is
by the way the largest private sector
aggregation of capital in human history
I've actually started studying this
going all the way back to the Dutch East
India Company and Beyond this is the
most powerful aggregation of corporate
capital in human history but they're
using the money of those everyday
citizens to tell oil companies to drill
for Less oil tech companies to an
operational hiring systems et cetera et
cetera et cetera well if you ask most
people in this country actually give a
homework assignment to anyone watching
the show literally go ask your financial
advisor go ask the person who runs your
401k plan at work was my money used to
vote in favor of a racial Equity audit
at Apple or a emissions cap at Chevron
first thing they'll tell you is they
don't know because they probably don't
tell them to find out you're almost
certain to find out the answer was
directly or indirectly yes
once you know that
it's you got to recognize it is your own
money that is actually being used to
vote for the very policies that we're
sitting here complaining I bet probably
directly or indirectly I'm I would be
willing to bet that most of the three of
you if not all three of you had your own
investment accounts in some way directly
and directly voting for those policies
once people wake up to that reality you
can move your own money in a way that at
least gets much further than the
government's going to get to in the next
25 minutes I made sure my mine is it by
the way right but so break this down for
us how would your money fall into the
hands of those companies yeah so it's
like a game of Plinko you've seen the
prices right you know that game that you
drop the plinkos yeah it's pretty good
so so there's there's a bunch of
intermediaries so let's say uh you know
I'll give you a couple different
Cascades let's say you are working at a
company you put your money in a 401k
account because you put that away
there's a tax advantage associated with
doing so whatever well that's invested
in index funds you don't know who those
index funds are because you have only a
menu that your 401k plan administrator
picks well those index funds tend to be
provided by the three largest asset
enter BlackRock State Street Vanguard
Invesco by the way is number four
they're not much better in this metric
now what do they do they use that money
to buy shares in publicly traded
companies across the American economy
that's what an index fund is you own the
index now with that comes not only a
financial entitlement which is the right
to receive the profits and dividends
that's what you get if you own a share
of a company but also the right to vote
because if you're a shareholder in this
company you have a right to actually
have say who runs the company how much
they're paid and so on however that
voting power rests with the index fund
manager the BlackRock the Vanguard of
the world and what they're doing now is
they're using that share to not vote for
what actually advances the financial
interests of the person that 401k
account but to implement someone else's
political agenda who's that someone else
actually turns out that's it's Calpers
it's California's pension fund system
that's the state of New York expansion
fund system who've explicitly starting
when Trump pulled out of the Paris
climate Accords this is about four years
ago they said that well look if the
government isn't going to address
climate change or racial Injustice then
we in the private sector have to do it
instead so we California and by the way
Norway or whoever else will do the same
thing we're going to pull our money from
you blackrocker Vanguard unless you use
everyone else's money that you manage to
vote this agenda in place and so they
drag everyone else along for the ride
because they know that Mom and Pop
working with their 401k account they're
not going to pay attention they don't
know what's going on so it was by design
that that's actually what's implementing
this agenda where if you put it in the
ballot box that say mom and pop would
say hell no if you ask them do you want
your money to be used to implement that
same climate agenda racial Equity agenda
they will still say hell no but little
do they know that they're hard-earned
dollars that they banked away in that
401k account was indeed the very weapon
that was used to implement that agenda
in the first place and it's not just
individuals it's also States it's also
countries entirely just giving all of
their money to these institutions and
not even knowing that they're doing so
and I believe it was West Virginia and
Florida are the only states that kind of
moved out of it away from the ESG score
which I think is worth noting here
because there is a way if people spread
this information enough there is a way
to to move away from the system that we
are incentivizing and giving money to
which is absolutely crazy and I think we
should stop immediately doing so and I
don't mean enemy to you know plug my own
stuff or whatever but just factually
speaking I didn't think I was going to
start another business I thought I was
done I hung the jersey and business
after biotech the reason I came back to
it is literally this is a problem that
is begging to be solved through the
market so that that's literally why I
started strive which is
to be a voice in the market that uses
shareholder power that tells these
companies to knock it off with the
politics and to focus exclusively on
making excellent products and services
to make money and to do it without
having to apologize for it and the irony
is like back in 1990 you would have said
this has been all this is this is the
most boring thing you possibly could do
yet today there is there's all there's
no other major firm I'm aware of that's
actually started doing it and you know
what's funny is we've I mean there's a
million things I would have done
differently three months in we cross
half a billion dollars took JP Morgan
when they entered the ETF business the
exchange rate funded business I'm told
over two years to cross a billion it's
like upstart we're three months in we
crossed half billion because of the
demand of the everyday citizen for this
basic alternative and voice can you
break down in layman's terms what it is
you do yeah so subscribe is basically
the new company I found it it is
competing directly with the likes of
BlackRock and State Street Vanguard
offering index funds ways to invest in
the market to own the companies in these
underlying indices but with a different
mandate to the underlying companies
using not not a gentle ask but using
shareholder power to mandate these
companies to focus exclusively on
products and profits over politics and
social agendas have you talked with uh
anyone in government in West Virginia or
Florida about I've been I've been
talking to people across the states in
in the country and it's been a wake up
it's been an exercise in in waking these
people up to what's happening in their
own backyard now the funny thing is a
lot of these folks are really happy in
red States and otherwise to point the
finger to Blackrock and State Street in
Vanguard and that's fine
when it's a lot harder for them to admit
what's happening in their own backyard
you're talking about the Deep State at
the federal level the Deep state within
the states is actually even more
eye-opening when you look at how Florida
or how even the state of Texas forget
blue States how those States Pension
funds even for the proxies the
shareholder votes that they cast
internally they're every bit as bad as
the ESG industrial complex at BlackRock
racial Equity audits at Amazon civil
rights representative on Facebook's
board without re-electing Peter thieler
Mark Andreessen they say they want to
re-elect them they want to point to
civil rights representative to
Facebook's board that's the State of
Florida right and so I think that I
think that you know like a lot of
conservatives a lot of red States
they're really good at pointing out the
problem in somebody else's yard but not
good enough at looking actually at the
at the Cesspool in even their own state
governments in their own backyards and
so one of the things I've been trying to
do is is and I've talked yes to all of
these states and more educating them
about what's even happening in their own
little fiefdom and the more people get
educated the more it becomes difficult
for them not to take action of some kind
I think that's what we're beginning to
see if social media allows you to have a
voice and I I absolutely agree with you
I do believe the market will uh is a way
better solution and should fix
everything but we have a lot of
socialism when it comes to a lot of
these government officials manipulating
the market for their own personal
benefit but at the end of the day for me
personally if you believe the government
is going to solve any problem you're
either insane or delusional so I'm with
you I think what you're doing is
exciting it sounds really awesome to be
honest with you and I think if more
people were aware like hey I'm you know
in in a red state but my retirement is
going to the ESG I think a lot of people
would act on it immediately I would and
I did personally too I have someone that
handles my retirement and I'm like I
don't want my money in any of this
nonsense and he handles it in a way
where he makes sure it doesn't
prioritize a lot of this bigger bullcrap
we talked with the state treasurer from
West Virginia came on the show last week
yeah Riley good right you've met him oh
yes awesome and he was telling exactly
written together that's what I I was
going to to ask you about he talked
about getting West Virginia out of all
the ESG companies saying we're not going
to do contracts with them these
companies were saying we will not
provide financing for the oil industry
for the coal industry for fossil fuels
and that's West Virginia strong point of
West Virginia so he said then get out we
need to see more of that here's here's a
I mean this is going to be probably
getting too boring and Technical for you
guys but I think I've learned is a lot
of the state treasurers have been making
a lot of noise turns out they don't have
a ton of power I I hope I don't upset
some of them by saying this I'm just
going to call it like I see it the real
money is in the pension fund systems
right so what the state treasurers have
is like a pittance they'll move a few
hundred million dollars which sounds a
lot on Fox news.com headline but is
actually a pittance compared to a 20
trillion dollar problem where the tens
or hundreds of billions are actually in
the pension systems and there you have
politically insulated actors right you
have actors who are designed to be not
responsive to the will of the everyday
citizens that are through layers and
layers of appointments the people who
sit on those bureaucratic bodies that's
really where the decisions get made so
you know even even that Florida decision
they pulled two billion from BlackRock
or whatever that was mostly cash and
short-term like fixed income like like
lending instruments nothing to do with
the equity problem which is owning
stocks and actually telling companies
how to behave that's in a different part
of a state bureaucracy's apparatus and
it's again the same problem that we're
talking about with the federal
government the whole FBI issue it's the
same same issue here too where the
people who we elect to run the
government are really good at projecting
to the public that they're able to
exercise actual political power
when in fact that only deepens the
problem because they're not even the
ones who are exercising the real
political power which is a bureaucratic
technocracy that sits up beneath the
level of detection that's really where
the meat is it absolutely is a political
bureaucracy and I know you're right that
it's not left versus right as simple as
that but once more these these
structures that actually extend to
things like Pension funds I don't think
we can Overlook that yeah these are all
leftists right so the thing with leftist
activists is that they are not just at
their job they are a leftist activist at
their job but that is exactly why
something like an ESG score even exists
in the first place and so what is
frustrating to me with the right is that
okay we are trying to further our agenda
by saying let's not be political a lot
of the times and a lot of time that's
all that the right is asking for is just
political neutrality I would like to see
the right fight back a little bit more
and say no that's actually not enough
right it's actually not just enough to
say oh we're going to care about
finances and not that your your firm
should be in this but individual
companies I would love to see more of
them actually say Hang on we're actually
afraid to say something that's
pro-abortion we want to be pro-life
because we know otherwise we're going to
be upsetting the conservative consumer
base just as much as we be we would be
upsetting the left wing rabid regressive
consumer base but unfortunately the
right is still not on the same cultural
level that the left is in that regard do
you see that viral video from uh is it
live action or live live action live
action see I always I always say one and
then think it's the other where uh this
woman she comes in and their boss and
the manager they're alike so we heard
the good news you know we heard news
you're pregnant she's like I am and
they're like let us know there's
anything we can do for you we'll get you
a flight you know whatever you need to
fly out of state you'll get you a really
nice hotel and she's like flight out of
state and I'm like right right you know
when do you think you get back to work I
think in a couple weeks and she's like
uh and then after giving birth they're
like oh we we meant you know so these
companies I think this one's obvious
they want to save money cheaper just
have a woman go get an abortion than it
is to actually provide benefits pay for
maternity leave as well as dependence on
the health care no it's it's being spun
as this feminist thing to pay for an
employee's abortion it's really just I
mean capitalism trying to get you back
to your nine to five which in other
circumstances feminist would oppose but
because it enables abortion they're
actually for it Kroger is one of the
places that said that they would come
and pay for abortions yeah Microsoft as
well there's a whole bunch of them I
encourage anyone who watches this to
actually look up those lists of
companies and stop shopping there
because otherwise you are literally
funding abortion that's not hyperbole
you you are financing these employees
abortions you got to vote with your
dollar I think a lot of people realize
that you have a lot more power when it
comes to deciding what you incentivize
than just going to that Ballot Box once
every four years yes so just to ask you
directly if you could have your way what
would happen how can we take action on
this how can we move forward if if you
were able to decide how we move forward
what would be the next step transparency
first of all so look the way I look at
it we live in a free country if you want
with your own money to advance an
environmental agenda or a social agenda
whatever that is pro-life agenda
pro-choice agenda whatever it is if you
want to do it with your own money we
live in a free country you're free to do
that but if you're not free to do it
with OPM okay other people's money okay
that's especially use it we talk about
that strive all the time okay you can't
do it with OPM so so if you're going to
do it with other people's money there's
a really simple standard you just need
to tell them you're doing it and you
need to get their consent so what
happens when every wealth manager every
401k account in Corporate America every
401k plan manager every pension fund
manager goes and asks the teacher the
doctor the nurse the engineer hey are
you cool with me using your money to
vote in favor of a racial equity-based
hiring system that's a effective quota
system in Corporate America most of them
are going to have a pretty clear answer
they're going to say hell no I'm not now
for the 20 or the 10 percent who's fine
with it that's great that restores
integrity back into the system and some
of those people are going to say you
know what I would trade off a few
dollars of investment return if you
actually make sure that these companies
Embrace pro-life causes and if you're
doing with that with your own money I'm
fine with that too but I would not be
fine with an asset manager even though
I'm right of Center it doesn't matter I
don't think an asset manager should be
using somebody else's money to fund a
pro-life cause without the capital owner
actually knowing it so so pretty simple
transparency disclosure consent and
actually prosecute bring civil action or
otherwise against the people who violate
those principles that's the challenge
though if they're not playing by the
rules and you are they're they're
winning well I'm a part of a part of the
role of a market actor is also to raise
hell and make sure that they are damn
well played by the same rules by the
time we're done with this and so this is
this is a bottom-up revolution not in
our politics but it's it's in our Market
because people are voting every day with
their dollars they just don't think of
themselves as voting as they do once a
year when they go to The Ballot Box
every November once they realize that
though that knowledge is the first step
to actually giving them Choice make sure
the other guy's feet are held to the
fire that they are playing by the same
rules we don't need to pass new laws for
this by the way most of these are
violations I believe of laws that are
already on the books basic fiduciary
principles if you're Sam bakeman freed
you cannot use a customer's funds in a
way that a customer did not agree to
without his permission that's the crime
on offer well I don't care if you dress
it up as he did actually by the way too
in an ESG clothing you could say the
same thing you can't use somebody else's
money to advance your own agenda without
telling them you're doing it unless you
get their permission same principles
just got to apply those standards
even-handedly adding red states are
slowly slowly beginning to wake up to it
and I think people really need to know
about this because I would be pissed my
money is going to promote wokeness but
also more importantly I think people
need to realize you're losing money
because you're incentivizing a lot of
this nonsense that doesn't make money
and at the end of the day your
retirement account is is losing on its
investment One Step where they're just
just since while we're on the on the
kick of pissing you off here so
so with one hand okay the black rocks of
the world are pressuring Exxon and
Chevron and others to effectively drill
for Less oil with emissions caps turns
out those companies have to drop oil
production projects to meet those Net
Zero standards by 2050. guess who's oh
no let me ask you just a question what
your net reaction is you may know where
I'm going with this so you may probably
get it right do you think those projects
are still proceeding or do you think
that they actually just got dropped in
the interest of staving off Global
emissions which do you think it is
between the two
um dropped no wrong answer actually
projects are proceeding they're just
proceeding under new ownership
so the firms that are buying up these
projects from Chevron include the likes
of Petro China on the other side of the
world
now you ask the final question guess
who's one of the largest shareholders of
petrochina
it is none other than BlackRock the very
firm that was actually pressuring the
excellent that Chevrons of the world
over here to drop those kinds of
projects that is how deep this runs you
don't know why because if you go to
China and they're going to establish an
ESG agenda and scope three emissions
targets they're going to tell you to get
the heck out and to shut the door on
your way out because we build a great
Chinese wall the Great Wall that stops
you from entering the Chinese market if
you're going to mess with our companies
but actually if you're also one of those
firms that's doing it to the us we'll
roll out the red carpet and that's
exactly why BlackRock became the first
foreign owner to win a license to sell
mutual funds in China a few years ago
because they were doing the bidding of
the CCP so this runs deep right and when
you have when you have sort of
concentrated nodes of private public
power in the United States that's what
lends it to capture even by other
governments like the CCP in a truly
decentralized free market system or in a
truly decentralized Democratic body
politic by the way that doesn't lend
itself to capture including by Foreign
actors but when you have that level of
concentration of both Capital but also
Capital coordinated with State action
that's what lends itself to capture from
abroad and that's the game the CCP has
actually mastered to this brings me to
something I've been talking about for a
very long time because we have seen a
lot of Western Elites a lot of Wall
Street firms prop up China and I think
they're using China as a vessel not only
to test out their Draconian Big Brother
totalitarian uh policies but more
importantly I think China is the
direction the whole world is going in
and we see individuals like Bill Gates
literally advise the Chinese government
I don't think that's a that's a
coincidence here what do you think is
really going on here how do you think
this is developing because for me
personally I'm seeing this as an attempt
by many Elites to make China as an
example for the rest of the world Klaus
Schwab even openly talks about this Bill
Gates openly compliments China with
their zero covet policies when they're
actually creating humanitarian crises
and violating human rights on so many
different levels so to me China is the
playground of the elites they're using
it for the future for everyone is that
correct or is that too much I I view it
uh just in Reverse whereas I think that
with people who you call the elites are
really just the circus monkeys okay Tim
Cook and Larry Fink are XI jinping's
circus monkeys he will say jump they
will ask how high because it actually
comes down to money right so so the game
we played in this country and by the way
there's not it's not just Democrat
Republic this is Democrats and
Republicans by the way starting in the
1990s had this philosophy of democratic
capitalism in the United States the way
it went was we're going to export Big
Macs and happy meals and somehow we're
going to imagine that spreads democracy
to places like China we're going to use
our money to get them to be more like us
what China realized and they're always
playing a longer game than we are is
that actually
we could turn that on its head we can
use our money access to our Market
to to get America to be more like us or
One Step better they realize they could
use our own money to get us to be more
like us because we're the ones who
invested there in the first place and
there's that old neoliberal neoliberal
idea that as a nation progresses
economically that naturally Liberty and
democracy will follow so that was the
idea with all the foreign
that's the idea with the foreign direct
investment to China not only do we get
all these cheaper Goods but hey we also
get to democratize them we get to make
them exactly Western like us uh you know
I grew up in China partially yeah um not
only in Hong Kong but also in Shanghai
and it was shocking absolutely
unbelievable the amount of progress and
development that happened while I was
living under there but the thing is they
I think they overestimated the draw that
American neoliberalism will have because
as China has gotten more developed it's
actually I mean people say it's
communist it's not really communist it's
the strange hybrid of state-run
authoritarianism they're actually seeing
the decadences of the West and they are
using the capital that the West has
essentially transferred over to them in
order to combat it directly right and we
see this through Tick Tock Chinese Tick
Tock is not the same as Western Tick
Tock you go on Western Tick Tock and
they're offering you up videos of trans
non-binary whatever Chinese Tick Tock is
actually educational math and
Engineering exactly and that's that's
not an accident that China is very aware
of the societal ills that the left had
or sorry that the West has basically the
same thing and they're actually trying
to encourage them abroad while limiting
it at home so you hit that in the nail
on the head there so there's no
distinction in China between economic
policy and military policy there are two
sides of the same coin okay so what's
what's really going on here is I think
it's their version or their vision of
the Trojan War okay Greece was not going
to defeat Troy militarily any more than
China is going to defeat the United
States militarily ain't gonna happen in
the foreseeable future okay but what
they realized is that we can give the
other side the gift they cannot resist
in Greece's case you give them the
Trojan Horse that we know they cannot
resist
with it for us absolutely it's global
capitalism itself that the illusion of
global capitalism itself that is the
sweet siren song that we know the
Western America in particular cannot
resist we will turn their own companies
Apple Airbnb Tick Tock as an app
whatever it is as Trojan horses to
undermine their system from within and
people pick on Tick Tock right now for
good reason I think it's a data
collection Trojan Horrors
forget the Chinese company right to buy
dance owns Tick Tock just take Airbnb
for example not a lot of people know
this but this is like front page Wall
Street Journal reporting three years ago
I wrote about a little bit more in my
book
Airbnb American company headquartered in
Silicon Valley ESG Darling by the way
put some neat little black Square on its
Instagram account to stand solidarity
with black lives matter okay what do
they do they are literally handing over
the American user data on their platform
including private messages between
people who rent and the hosts on their
platform geolocational data Etc as a
condition for doing business in China
they don't get to do business in China
unless they hand that over do they tell
us users that they're doing it
absolutely not wow did their Chief
privacy officer resign yes he did but
you know Nate lecharcik he was a couple
years ahead of me in college what did he
say he was quoted and saying it
internally at their meeting we're not
here we're saying we're not here to
promote American values so we in America
are fine with that we think that
companies should not exist to promote
American values they should exist to
sell goods and services but the problem
is on a global stage China does believe
that those companies exist to promote
Chinese values and unless they abide by
that they don't get to do business there
so that's how they've actually turned
our own game on its head and here we are
playing along going along for the ride
10 years from now if we wake up to today
I think there's something we can do
about it 10 years from now wait to wake
up to the
same with our lack of capital controls
this is especially a problem in Canada
but you have all of these Chinese
property buyers who are not only buying
residential areas you know entire
projects but also buying up things like
ports right so it's not just the
financial system we're actually talking
about physicality China owns the West
this is not even mentioning the amount
of dollars that they have in reserve
right so I I get that people are saying
oh this is a problem we need to address
militarily China doesn't really need to
lift a finger in terms of arms to I I
would say fatally hurt the American
system at this point they have police
departments inside of the United States
and Canada from the Chinese government I
mean they have a lot of sphere of
influence but they wouldn't be here if
it wasn't for Henry Kissinger and David
Rockefeller going over there and opening
up China to the world that's the nice
phrase that they use but in in all
actuality they just used China as a
vehicle to spread globalization they
took all the factory jobs from the
United States they shipped it over there
and they made a deal with with China
saying hey we're going to be working
with you guys one-on-one this is the
pathway Way by Henry Kissinger that led
us here and now we're in this situation
that you're describing you're totally
right all right Kissinger screwed up
no no no no no Kissinger doesn't screw
up Kissinger I think is is a brilliant
human being and I think a lot of his
screw-ups actually do benefit a lot of
his friends okay because I'm just
screwed up in screwed up maybe the wrong
word screwed up yes you're screwed
everyone else over for the benefits
usually these legacies screwed us okay
now though that's the easy part
identifying that in the rear view mirror
and blaming you know correctly correctly
assigning blame is the first step fine
what do we do about it the question is
there is a going to be a sacrifice it is
not a small sacrifice it will be very
big sacrifice an economic sacrifice that
we're gonna have to be willing to make
to say that we're not going to defeat an
enemy who we depend on to supply our
iPhones and our movies and the sneakers
that we wear on a given day is that a
sacrifice we're willing to make we're
not even willing to make a sacrifice to
ban Tick Tock cause kids are so addicted
to it what level of sacrifice are we
going to be willing to make goes back to
the thing I said earlier it's like given
cocaine to the drug addict okay if the
drug addict can't say no to the thing
they're addicted to they're just heading
in their in down the road to the black
hole of their own misery that's where we
are in our relationship with China right
now we don't have it in us we don't have
the fortitude to cut ourselves off from
the Comforts that we're going to have to
give up in the short run in order to fix
this for the long run well if you look
at China's model of economic nationalism
there are things that the U.S could copy
essentially and and ensure that they
take greater control of their own
companies their own Capital but like you
said they're not going to do it and I
bring this back to movies because again
mediaholic Channel China you actually
they limit the number of foreign movies
that you can bring into China every
single year and obviously China is this
huge market for movies a lot of Revenue
so what Hollywood does is that they
actually do joint Partnerships with
Chinese production so if you ever
wondered why there are so many different
movies that are filmed in places like
Shanghai and Hong Kong counts for these
purposes though it's an SAR it is
because if you partner with Chinese
production then you get to skirt around
the quota now you're no longer one of
the made 10 films or whatever it may be
that they released from foreign foreign
production houses now you actually count
as local so you can give as many movies
as you want in China you take a greater
share of the cut and what that means is
that actually Hollywood is funding the
Chinese Communist party uh and and it's
it's a smart move but you see the United
States like you said they would never
ever do something that bold I guess that
economic not economically National
they're not strong enough to do the only
thing I would say Lord is is one thing
we've got to be careful of and I see
this a little bit of the sloppiness on
the right sometimes there could be two
very different justifications for taking
similar courses of policy one is just
straight up economically protectionist
which is to say that oh they took our
jobs and you know we need to we need to
you know they're they're making stuff
cheaper than we are here I'm not super
sympathetic to the economically
protectionist account of giving and
coddling the American worker what I'm
talking about is the National Security
side of the line and actually it turns
out that a lot of these policies can
point in the same direction but when
China is viewing economic policy and
military policy as two sides of the same
coin I think that when it comes to a
national security question we got to
treat it as a national security issue
that defends us against the one threat
that actually matters to the United
States that's not in Iraq Afghanistan
Russia Ukraine is China but I think that
we got to be careful not to make that a
sloppy way into anti-meritocratic
American worker coddling which I think
we could use less of rather than more
even though sometimes on the right
people end up conflating you know a lot
of that's where I part ways with Josh
Hawley and and whatnot is the
justification for taking courses of
action that might make sense for
National Security grounds don't work for
me if it's just anti-meritocratic
laziness well I think we're at a point
now where people would be more willing
to accept some economic protectionism if
it's in the name of National Security
after covid right because so many people
saw that hey we don't actually make a
lot of drugs in the United States
anymore we don't make a lot of PPE in
the United States anymore so there are
definitely certain industries where I
think people would be willing to say
let's make the sacrifice in order to
support American Business we already see
that historically with American Steel
right because we understand the
importance of wartime I I don't think
people would be as willing to do that
for when it comes to those cheap Goods
that we can get at the dollar store
right because the the average consumer
is going to think why am I paying more
for I I don't know whatever it may be my
toothbrush now for for my iPhone now
like how is this part of National
Security that would be a really hard
sell in terms of policy to the to the
public
I don't have an answer for that
yeah I mean I think I think any time the
litmus test for me is if China is using
a company as a vehicle to advance a
geopolitical goal we need to treat that
as what it is it is a geopolitical
question it is a security question it is
not just an economic question where does
that leave us probably Banning Tick Tock
um I think I mean not just Tick Tock
NBA as well we see them pushing this
leftist agenda they have big contracts
with China and they won't say a thing
about free speech I mean it's it's even
something as simple some might say
apolitical as Sports there's also the
economic incentive like China is in that
they are controlling that that's why
Lebron James despite all his BLM
activism won't say a thing about the
Euchre Muslims yeah I mean these are
again circus monkeys of the CCP as I
said earlier do you think there could be
a market solution to this because I'm
thinking about this and I just don't
want the government deciding what we can
and cannot see I think a bigger solution
and this is just me being optimistic is
giving people uh an internet Bill of
Rights where you have your data you
protect your data and I I think the
reason why they're all this sabotaged
and spying and fifth generational
Warfare is going on because it's not
just benefiting the Chinese it's also
benefiting the American deep state
they're getting data sets their Facebook
knows when you take a dump they know
everything you do and they have garnered
someone you know what I was about to
give birth exactly because I was
Googling like pregnancy stuff they knew
that newborn was coming but there's
advertisements being sent to mothers
that that are sent before they even know
that they're pregnant themselves based
on their behaviors and activities that
they commit on social media so so I I
think the once that moving forward is
saying hey your data you control it uh
and if you want to sell it to another
company you have that right to do that
is there a possibility for that to
happen rather than the government coming
in and just Banning these accounts
because I think also there needs to be a
lot more public awareness at the
severity of just this kind of deep State
spying that's happening I mean I've seen
Libertarians argue that even something
like a Bill of Rights for the internet
would be government action in and of
itself because you can't forget if
there's an internet Bill of Rights that
also necessitates that there's some sort
of penalty or enforcement so so I think
you're talking about fancy Solutions in
terms of Market Solutions I think
there's actually lower hanging fruit
just to keep it even simpler
I think in the same way that
globalization represented an opportunity
in the 1990s from it just from its raw
investment perspective I think
de-globalization represents a massive
investment opportunity from a capital
allocation perspective over the next 10
years ahead as well and you know so I'll
give you I'll give you one small example
right I Still Company I've done business
in China before by the way and I was
exchange student my senior year of
college at Peking University that's you
know sort of the Harvard of China they
call it done business in China
thereafter
seen what that looks like
I said that what I found at strive I
said look we're not going to do business
in China we're not we're going to make
that commitment on day one why do I say
that is that because I dislike the CCP I
personally dislike the CCP it has
nothing to do with it as to the fact
that you can't be a good fiduciary to an
American Consumer managing Americans
funds speaking as a vocal shareholder on
behalf of American clients if you have
the boot of the CCP on your neck now I
think that that is actually a business
opportunity to operate with greater
Integrity serving the American consumer
unapologetically in a way that the
pendulum when it swung so far in One
Direction you know is sort of a classic
maxim of Warren Buffett be brave when
others are fearful be fearful when
others are brave to actually be contrary
and go in the other direction to be an
even better Steward for the American
customer by differentiating yourself by
making sure that the thing that
differentiates you is that you are not
under the bear hug or under the auspic
or with a gun to your head from the CCP
and so I I just think that
de-globalization broadly and a
willingness to invest to serve the
citizens of Nations rather than Global
Citizens can itself be an economic
opportunity that defines probably great
businesses that can be built on the back
of that over the next decade now
operationalizing that into an internet
through a tech-based infrastructure or
the blockchain or what ever else I mean
that that gets complicated Free Speech
Bill of Rights or or Internet Bill of
Rights you know that those are all
thorny issues we could spend a five hour
discussion on in their own right but I
just think about even basic business
Builders and entrepreneurs stepping up
and saying that I can in order to put my
American customer first that itself is a
business opportunity that I can liberate
myself from even if that means
sacrificing the extra 30 of the
opportunity that I could have gotten by
going to China I think we're going to
see more of that Lauren if I could just
ask you because I grew up in Poland
during communism my family tells me all
these crazy stories about what they have
to go through because of the the KGB and
the government there do you have similar
stories growing up in China does your
family tell you stories of of maybe how
the social credit score was being put
into place or anything like that I
mostly grew up in Hong Kong my dad is
Cantonese from Hong Kong
um I My Views about uh I guess the
benefits versus cons of British
colonialism have gotten me on trouble
and Trouble on on Twitter many a time
um so you know my my parents they
they've been in Hong Kong during things
like the umbrella protests and
personally I've witnessed that every
time I go back to Hong Kong you see more
and more actual propaganda and for
anyone who's not familiar with Hong Kong
it is one of the most developed and I
guess financially free places on on the
planet right 15 was right 15 flat tax uh
you know you're walking down the Main
Street and they're all these Major
Brands uh Dior Schnell you name it now
with CCP propaganda covered over it so
this is absolutely absolutely something
that's gotten increasingly worse over
the past past few years and you know
there's footage of people doing things
like trying to rip down uh those those
data hubs essentially that are are
trying to monitor your face so this is
something that I mean you know it's even
more recent and that's what's so scary
about it because you you hear about
these losses of freedoms and you think
maybe Soviet Union or a generation ago
you know maybe even further back but no
this is actually some freedoms are
actually something that you can lose in
real time and heck even I'm gonna bring
it to Canada that my nationalities have
not been uh doing too well in terms of
safe guarding Liberties I'm also
Canadian it's the same I'm saying Canada
as well I mean you're freezing bank
accounts now so like where where are
these people supposed to go at a certain
point when literally I would say most
nations are backsliding yeah I mean I
was in Hong Kong during a lot of the
protests there and the way that the
Chinese government squashes protests and
and the measures that they put in is
absolutely terrifying I I've talked to a
lot of the protesters there I've done on
the ground reporting I was in the tear
gas I was in the craziness and just the
level of sophistication when it comes to
their intelligence surveillance State
Police state it is terrifying right and
I think I you know I've spoken with my
husband about this before uh if we are
in a situation where Liberty is
essentially dissolving everywhere we go
I would rather live in a state that is
at least less physically and
technologically capable of oppressing
you than one that is right which is why
there are so many people that I know
just personally incompetent dictatorship
rather than a competent one exactly
you're right and that's something that I
think Rousseau has kind of written about
I I would rather other at least a
dictator who's only got a limited reach
due to limited resources rather than I
mean somewhere like Hong Kong like China
like Canada and I would say in a lot of
ways yeah like Europe we're going to go
to super chess now so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and become a
member over at timcast.com we are going
to have a members only show coming up we
those are up around 11 p.m eastern time
so we record those usually after we wrap
but we're gonna Read Super chats from
you so again smash that like button
let's uh read some of your comments and
I'll just I'll just uh address everybody
in the chat I am sleeping actually it is
because I'm very tired because we flew
out here we did the show it's work work
work and then uh today not only did I do
my morning show I also recorded for
prageru which was really awesome they
were awesome and then we're here and
then so then once you everybody got into
it I was like man they're holding it
down I'm gonna chill and then we'll get
to the super chats and here we are so
let's read
all right autistic musings says why
don't you ask your your politician
guests why they aren't running on
getting the Epstein Client List exposed
you would think there is no better
platform to run on than that and it
unifies people too from the left and the
right A lot of people know that the the
whole Jeffrey Epstein Saga doesn't add
up doesn't make any sense you could
unify America with it yeah but but you
know Luke we just saw a handful of
politicians at TP USA and you were
asking about church commissions yeah
absolutely what about Epstein Church
commissions would probably expose what
happened with Epstein and again if
people don't know what happened with
Epstein it's an international
trafficking extortion operation run by
the intelligence agencies for over 30
plus years so high levels of the
government big Banks all involved in
trafficking small children the most
unspeakable sickest nastiest things that
happen in this world the fact that the
The Client List is still not released
shows you just how corrupt our whole
institution is and how the intelligence
agencies probably have a lot of dirt on
all of our politicians especially
individuals like Bill Gates look at your
shirt man huh I'm looking at your shirt
yes I I really do love that we're we're
going into the holidays and uh well we
did with Thanksgiving but also with this
Christmas everyone's gonna have the
opportunity to be like so that Epstein
thing was true huh
Jones was right Alex Jones was right
Dollar in the jar that's right everybody
I have like 15 Epstein shirts just to
get the conversation started and it's
[ __ ] up so I mean no better way I mean
this is something that everyone on the
left and right agrees on I mean there's
should be a major talking point and it's
not yeah absolutely all right we got
Beavis McLean who says Tim quit stealing
my spoons and hiding them on the moon a
demand that you put pictures of my
favorite people you Luke Ian and
possibly Michael malice in Times Square
and I can forgive you for the thefts
um me uh I uh Luke Ian we are in Times
Square right now it's actually really
crazy plus um right on the North Tower
on the ground there's two three-sided
it's like a big screen it's like a cube
and it says Tim guest IRL it looks
pretty good you saw it yeah I saw it
yeah I saw a couple weeks ago there was
some Ad Agency in my DMs and I had
checked out their profile they're legit
they wanted to get on a call with me
about like purchasing stuff in Times
Square it's like I don't know who you
think I am that I like could we've been
on this show yeah well I guess and they
think I have billboard money it's like
that no we did it for New Year's so it's
going to be up on New Year's when
everyone's filming you're gonna it's
gonna big Tim casts and so doing that is
about sending a message we we want to be
in the cultural spaces we want to be
dominating the cultural spaces so one
thing I'm really really excited about is
in the next couple of weeks we're going
to be setting up a coffee shop
and then we're going to hopefully have
10 coffee shops in a year or two then
we're going to have 20 coffee shops
maybe a thousand but these are places
people can go and hang out these are
places where you'll walk in order the
physical world who would have thought of
it physical world you'll walk in to buy
a coffee and there will be TVs playing
this show playing Pop Culture crisis
Tales from the inverted World we'll also
have your show playing we will have
people that we think are sending good
messages just as the default content
when you're sitting down having a coffee
oh wait I know what the audience is
wanting to know I saw this on Twitter
the suggestion is it going to be called
the coffee beanie no because the Coffee
Bean already exists it's a chain of
coffee shops yeah so there was a there's
a coffee shop in uh New Haven that's
called uh blue State coffee based on
being a blue state or whatever
um I always thought there was an
opportunity for a red State coffee
actually I know it doesn't have to be it
has to be a partisan thing but a place
where people get together with common
interest to have a conversation I hope
that's part of I hope that's part of
your yeah the first division the first
one we're setting up it's a coffee shop
it's going to have a place for playing
music small stage and then we're gonna
do Ian's Crystal Cave Cove or whatever
small Stage Music that's pretty good
yeah but then second floor is going to
be like skate shop and games so you can
get a coffee go up play board games uh
skate stuff third floor we're gonna have
a podcast Studio setup so that way we
can do special Friday night shows
members only can come and hang out in
the first floor
yeah a lot of people like an audience
yeah but maybe very very limited to
members it might be only a small handful
of people drinking having a drink or
something hopefully we get a liquor
license and then you know at this
location man yeah we got the building
and building exists an audience live
show would be incredible we we can't do
that the new building we got because
it's just not structured that way but
we're hoping to we've been trying to do
this for a while now hopefully we can
have a bunch of these small little
venues and then people can come and hang
out and meet like-minded people but
mainly we're gonna have comedians oh
yeah absolutely okay I'm working on
stand-up my husband is sure that I'll
bomb but I would love to bomb at your
place oh you'd be great we'll get Ryan
long to come out no what okay
give us a joke he's crazy Lauren right
now give us a joke come on confused you
guys have to wait here's one thing I
promise you we're not gonna put in our
Windows BLM signs antifa signs or please
do not hurt us signs we're going to put
molan labe the Gadsden flag the American
flag Etc
let's read some more drive by commenter
says Hi everyone and Vivek from y'all's
experience is there any way for
Americans to resist the adoption of
social credit through
cdbcs what is that cbdc is talking about
so Central Bank digital currency yeah
okay
yeah so are you I mean I mean so Central
Bank digital currencies I think are
going to be uh gaining a lot of
popularity as a response to what
happened with FTX I think they're going
to use the fall of FTX to say that
cryptocurrency is not where it's at if
you want to go digital do it through the
central bank now the irony is that the
number one justification for Central
Bank digital currencies so this is
thinking about the equivalent of a
digital dollar is that China's already
doing it with the digital Yuan and so
the way the economic argument goes in
the United States is that the dollar is
going to be less strong relative to the
Yuan if we don't keep up with the
Joneses if we don't keep up with China
and China's doing it because this is a
great way of effectuating centralized
control over your population if you can
literally go in and tie somebody's
actual net worth to their social credit
score then the way in which their
behaviors align or don't align with the
government can literally can literally
correspond to the number of digital
points in their bank account which is
today the green pieces of paper in your
wallet so that's why China's doing it my
view is I think that the keeping up with
the Joneses argument is completely
backwards because let's say every other
major Nation does go the direction of
China
I actually think that will make the
dollar relatively more valuable and
distinctive to be the currency that does
not actually subject itself to the same
debasement and co-option by actually
becoming a vehicle for exercising
governmental control so this whole
strong Dollar in order for the dollar to
remain strong it must actually keep up
with what the yuan is doing is actually
backwards the fact that China is doing
it creates an opportunity for
distinctiveness for the dollar to remain
the actual last Reserve currency of the
world if we don't subject ourselves to
that same downward spiral so this
question was how do we actually do it I
think this is an electoral Democratic
accountability issue it's going to take
an uprising of everyday citizens to
stand up and say no we're not doing that
thank you very much no thank you we're
not going I mean we already see the end
result of this happening in places like
Canada War the way they were freezing
bank accounts and even if the US doesn't
have this I guess at a systemic level I
mean if you look at what PayPal recently
tried to do through I mean finding
people up to 2500 for posting
misinformation that's still there the
policy is still there yeah they snuck it
back in right they
they said it was a mistake so so the
first response was to say that no no
that was just an error yet it was
coincidentally an error that they
purposefully reinstated a matter of days
later yeah curious fact cheers
I think everyone got the story wrong
it's been a while since I covered this
but I think they implemented some policy
then there was some language came out
that was worse and they said no that was
a mistake but the other policy it had
been there for a couple of years yeah
core policy about finding you for
spreading misinformation or whatever was
was still there so I don't think so now
imagine that's not PayPal doing it's
just the government doing it right
because
I guess the point is is there any is it
any better if it just happens to be
PayPal but also all of your different
banks we see people like Laura Loomer
like Nick Fuentes they essentially can't
bank now I think Nick Fuentes posted on
his telegram he he's gotten kicked out
of his fifth bank I mean obviously it's
not as bad as a the federal government
doing it but we have some level of this
already in the United States well the
federal government actually confiscated
a half a million dollars from and and
still has not given it back that's crazy
man all right let's read this from
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim to be
honest I've missed it Blissful ignorance
but I'll never go back I'll never stop
now you keep being a voice for our
movement and we'll do our darndest to
support and fight to save our nation
amen well I appreciate all of your
support he's making a reference
something I said earlier I said the idea
that ignorance is bliss is not true
because today you can see that in
people's ignorance they're left confused
wondering why it is they're losing
purchasing power why their why their
homes are being foreclosed why there's
war and escalation ignorance is actually
making people quite the opposite of
blissful at this point
our College's empowerment yep yeah it is
and and you know people man maybe
knowing the truth might suck in a
certain sense being pulled out of the
Matrix you know when uh what's his name
Cipher was eating that steak and he says
I don't care what it is it just tastes
good yeah
but the thing about the Matrix was that
you were safe in your little pot and you
were warm the reality is that's not the
case you stay in the Pod you lose your
house you lose your job you end up
homeless and hungry and confused as to
why it happened so we got to wake people
up we got to tell people to be
responsible
all right let's read this
John Doherty says had to search the show
tonight no notification you pissed them
off again Tim and crew congratulations
keep up the great work thank you so much
for what you do thank you for the Super
Chat yeah I I actually believe they
probably try to suppress this show
Hunter Biden laptop in the title oh yeah
yeah of course but but or I says Hunter
Biden censorship uh I think so many
people share the show and come to the
show that they keep trying to suppress
it it just doesn't work because we've
got
people who share it that weight is hard
to counter
Jonathan e says in October the
post-millennial reported about a man
joining a sorority at U Wyoming recently
a Laramie resident got suspended for
tabling at UW for a sign saying the man
is male now Wyoming state government is
threatening to cut UW funding free Todd
Schmidt wait are you saying that Wyoming
is going woke is that what they're doing
is that the story is I mean it sounds
like it from that description I heard
about the first part I haven't heard
about the sign no man
well you know what they say get what go
broke but uh as much as people like to
think that means the industries will
eventually learn their lesson what's
happening is the country is just getting
woken going broke so hopefully we we you
know yeah Doug Phelps says the FBI is
working just as J Edgar Hoover designed
and used it they removed Hoover but his
organization is still in place
so it was like a zombie zombie chicken
with his head cut off
yeah the Beast lives on that's and
that's the point liberals need to wake
up to this too is it's not about one
side or the other it's about the Beast
that actually outlasts both of them so I
think it's I think he's dead right and I
think that that framing is useful
because it can awaken a level of
political consensus amongst the
citizenry of this country to take this
issue off the axis of partisanship so
thanks to whoever said that because I
think that'll actually bring about 10 15
20 more people Along on this than if we
just made this about the hunter Biden
story and they need to realize the Iron
Fist that they're propping up is going
to back on them very soon you look up
cone toll probe look at the activities
of what the FBI was doing to to JFK to
MLK and be prepared to be surprised and
shocked Doc Holliday says Luke is
suffering from severe TDS
that's your opinion I just like to call
you know I like to call the facts out I
don't think I said anything that was
incorrect yeah called called I know
which is which is absolutely ridiculous
I mean Bill O'Reilly called me again a
Jihad loving liberal uh so so people
just I I guess I mean have I said
anything that was incorrect if so let me
know I I would love to correct my record
from derangement but but I I think it's
also important to note that he did some
good things he did some bad things but
we need to call it out and we need to
keep people in check no matter who they
are even if you like them or don't like
them I don't care you have power it
deserves to be checked and held
responsibly all right sleep is the
cousin of death says the way Donald
tried to appease the media is uh our our
we see you appeasing YouTube well
I guess I suppose I don't see Trump as
strong uh I don't see necessarily the
same way Trump knew people were going to
lie about him and chose to do interviews
with him anyway we kind of use YouTube
because we want to stay on the main
centralized platform where most young
people are it's the most prominent
social media platform used among gen Z
and it is the second biggest search
engine in the world so it's a
double-edged sword I suppose I haven't
faced two bad choices you know you might
just change the game in the long run but
you'll you'll make that you'll make the
choice you have to make in the meantime
but this is why we have timcast.com and
why we have the members only uncensored
portion so that we can be on YouTube
tell people
go to the website learn more and uh
support sort of the best way we can do
it for now you know or we can stop I'd
rather not do that we'll keep going
let's read some more
all right sorta says great to see Temple
and Lauren Chen in the same podcast love
you too Luke very cool appreciate it
thank you
all right let's go let's jump down okay
so because I read that one about Luke
having TDS I'll also read this one for
him essay federali says Luke is the goat
there you go nice
uh Voldemort Perez Jr says Tim the clip
you are talking about was Dan Pina on
London real or is it Dan Pena I don't
know but yeah it's a viral video where
he's like they're buying Miami beach
front property and none of these none of
the prospectus will say this is going to
be underwater in 40 years because they
don't believe it
Damien Master says FBI literally working
under Trump to tilt the election in his
competitors favor crazy
at the very least to protect the Biden
family
and I I while they while he was running
for office and there was evidence of
corruption and malfeasance I mean it's
more than just Trump's competitor it is
a guy who by all accounts if you look at
this laptop was committing some crimes
and or illicit business dealings say the
least
so even if he wasn't running it was
still like as a private citizen
Josh oh my gosh says my friend has
family in Ukraine and he tells me peace
talks won't happen because Putin was
attacking Ukraine while the talks were
happening how do we know one way or
another
you know anything about it Luke
no from that particular point no I mean
but we know for certain that at one
point zielinski was willing to have
those talks right I heard that started
on zielinski were supposed to sit down
together and and they already made a
partial deal that they agreed agreed to
the deal made sense both parties lost
out obviously when negotiations
and even Henry Kissinger the the war
criminal the The Butcher of Cambodia is
coming out and saying hey yeah we we
need uh we need a peace deal here and
his peace deal is Ukraine possibly
conceding some land here so this is
Henry Kissinger saying this and if the
war criminal Henry Kissinger is saying
hey we need a peace deal that's when you
know we've gone too far
all right Josh M says Elon says he is
stepping down as soon as he finds
someone foolish enough to take the job I
think Jack Dorsey is the best possible
option no now that it's under private
ownership I believe in second chances no
no no okay so not Jack Dorsey is trying
to essentially give himself a makeover
as if our Collective memory is that of a
goldfish okay he's trying to make it
seem like now he's pro-free speech there
are two options either he's lying and he
was on board with all the censorship and
the backhanded deals with the federal
government the whole time or he was too
incompetent to know about it in either
case he is not the man for the job agree
I think it's I think he was removed from
the situation I mean he was he was
meditating in Myanmar and in French
Polynesia which to be fair if I had
billions I would be doing as well so but
the reality is it's just this managerial
class again if it's the same way you
think the people who you like to run the
government don't run the government we
talked about that earlier the same thing
is true for most large companies the
people who you think are appointed in
the role of CEO don't really run that
company and it was the managerial class
at Twitter that ran the show it's like
the Deep state in the federal
government's deep corporate in Corporate
America and so you know I I actually
um I'm a little bit I have a little bit
of a softer corner for Jack Dorsey
amongst the Twitter critics which I'm of
the old Twitter critics which I'm
definitely squarely in the camp of is
criticizing The Assault on Free Speech
culture I actually think this was a
Founder who whose initial Vision was
actually to as Twitter State admission
was to break down barriers on the
internet I think that's actually part of
what he was motivated by eventually the
managerial class around him just started
to ossify around this other consensus
the guy checks out and says I'm going to
I'm going to crypto world and I'm going
to Myanmar but I think that that's a
different basis for disqualification
rather than the fact that he was
actually a pro-censorship dude which I
think misses the essence of what's
actually going on all right Marie gray
says please read this Super Chat Canada
is getting ready to vote on a bill that
will allow the state to euthanize
children who want to be euthanized
without their parents knowledge or
consent
diet yeah absolutely and there are stats
is going around that say potentially
medically assisted suicide is now one of
the top five leading causes of death in
Canada they're talking about killing the
mentally there was this one really
hilarious tweet I wish I could take
credit for it but it says essentially
kill yourself is both a slow a term that
can get you kicked off Twitter or is
Health Care advice from the Canadian
government
Eric says Vivek how do I get my 401K
money to strive from my 401k which is
hosted at Fidelity well thank you man I
appreciate that I think one of the my
main question is my main suggestion is
educate yourself and make sure your 401k
plan administrators themselves educate
themselves because right now most wealth
managers most 401k account plan
administrators most pension fund boards
most pension fund investment staff have
no idea about the things I was even
talking about here so when this has to
be a bottom-up revolution where it takes
a lot in order to get on a 401K platform
I don't think most of our money very
tiny portion of it comes from 401ks
because once you're a new player it
takes a huge process to get added on
those platforms so what I would say is
show up ask netplan administrator the HR
representative at work get in touch with
them and just ask them a simple question
was your money used to advance a just
give two examples racial Equity audit
Apple
or was it used to vote in favor of the
2021 scope 3 emissions proposal at
Chevron those are very two answerable
questions get that answer tell all of
your colleagues then I think that forces
them to actually create an alternative
and I hope there are many other
Alternatives I hope it's not just strive
hope there are many other Alternatives
eventually that people can choose from
that's the answer in the meantime most
of the I believe most of the people who
have actually helped get strive off the
ground
um you know actually just come from
their own brokerage accounts not
necessarily from 401K plans or pension
plans I hope that changes next year am I
the only one in light of all of the the
trans agenda the climate agenda that
when I hear about something like a
simple racial affirmative action process
I'm like oh how quaint the good old days
right yeah
I still cringe equally yeah it's still
bad but it's like oh at least no one's
no one's trying to shove drag queens
down five-year-olds
it's the sacrificing of Merit that I
think bothers me the most I agree I
agree Kevin Brady says Tim it's
important to remember that darpa's life
log was squashed the same day that
Facebook launched they served the same
purpose look at what life log was I'm
looking at you Luke what is it
um off the top of my head I don't
remember it but I I do know there's a
big connection between DARPA and a lot
of these uh big tech companies uh but
I'm gonna have to look that up I don't
like talking about stuff that I don't
have the notes on yeah I I think and I
could be wrong is that it was an attempt
to track people's lives create a record
of their lives or something to that
effect that's why it's called life log
that seems fairly obvious and then
Facebook someone's sitting there and
he's like why why are we spending all
this money to try and track people let's
get them to track themselves they'll
write everything about themselves
wherever they want you know what I mean
and then there you go it's genius if you
really think about it it's like bagging
the groceries at the end of the line you
know just let the customer do the final
piece yeah exactly yeah we're not going
to hire anybody anymore I remember when
they had a cashier and a bagger and now
it's just the cashier and then you've
got to put the stuff there and and you
go around that's right so they figured
out now they got self checkout yeah just
make you do the work we'll keep the
money no it's just one person watching
people right you're not as long as you
allow them to post it they're gonna do
it for you exactly it's perfect perfect
end around
American white guy says Tim what if they
realized that the dollar will mean
nothing and pushing this woke agenda is
being done to cause
decisiveness to push us to Civil War
over insanely different realities Maybe
divisiveness
yeah quite possibly we were talking
about this how uh you know Luke
mentioned that they want to divide and
conquer and the division now is among
those who want Division and those who
don't who are divided against those who
want division is the weirdest thing the
woke people want racial segregation and
gender segregation then you have the
meritocrats who are just like just be a
good person and be good at what you do
but there's a divide between the two
it's just the weird and then you have
the wonderful Michael Mouse's of the
world that are pushing the national
divorce who say I have nothing to do
with it and this guy I've been talking
about it for a very long time uh because
you know if you want to reduce harm that
could be one potential way of doing it
it could also lead to a lot of harm as
well yeah and also I also don't think
we're we're nearly there yet I think
even the people who are hungering for
that Division and this is a maybe a
charitable interpretation of it I think
there's a lot of it that's true
it may even come from any of them from a
good place where they're as I said
earlier so hungry for the sense of
purpose that's unfulfilled especially
why you see it amongst people more under
the age of 40 when it comes to wokism is
that we want to address that division
fill that hunger with something else
rather than telling them they go to Ben
and Jerry's and order a cup of ice cream
with some social justice sprinkles on
top they don't fill that moral hunger
with fast food okay if we can fill that
hunger with something else I think
that's going to be much better than
taking even seriously the idea that this
was what they even wanted just because
it's like it's like a baby you gotta be
here you had a baby recently I have a
two-year-old had a baby earlier this
year too it's like when they're hungry
for real food you give them a pacifier
they stop crying because they think
they're not hungry anymore well they're
really just hungering for real food and
I think we got to see them as crying for
what they're really crying out for which
is something of real purpose and meaning
and substance to satisfy that vacuum and
I I think that's going to get us there
sooner than talking about some sort of
bifurcation or national divorce oh no
exit I'm very very optimistic I've
already thought about it if Alberta does
separate I would gladly trade in my
Canadian citizenship for I don't know
like western Canada or whatever it may
be and I think seriously talking about
that oh yeah yeah it's gaining momentum
I'm a huge supporter of it and I think
what what really pushed a lot of people
over the edge I was always for it was
the coveted policies and the breakdown I
think a lot of people you know I don't
think you're wrong about the what got so
many people there where they're willing
to do something like support those
extreme policies but I think for people
like myself it's just like all right you
know hopefully somehow we can
de-radicalize a lot of the
authoritarianism that's creeped into our
crap into our society but until then I
am putting myself in a position where my
my neighbors want to remove me from
public life it's a tough one I don't
think America is here yet as much as
places like Canada but it's dangerous
because people are being radicalized the
key factors for people being radicalized
is poverty intelligence and lack of of
relationships modern men have all of
that right now and it's only going to be
increasing from here more people are
going to be radicalized we're going to
be living in a more dangerous society
and I think what Luke is saying about
peaceful divorce is because
you could make the argument that we're
in a fifth generational Warfare the
culture fifth generational Civil War
we're in fifth generational Warfare this
uh the culture what you mean by that
yeah fifth generational yeah this is uh
psychological operations manipulation
essentially false Flags I mean the stuff
you see with hoax hate crimes fake news
in the media it's an attempt to gain
control of a population without using
Force by just getting them to to
acquiesce to your your way of life so we
live in a constitutional republic but
now we have a constitutional republic in
the same space as a multicultural
democracy and those two forces are
fighting each other that may eventually
but you know a ferment a a peaceful
divorce or a violent one or something
I'm going to propose something that I'm
I'm going to caveat this by saying I'm
not yet there yet okay in terms of being
in favor of this but you just drew a
distinction that actually you're in a
really important point we live in a
constitutional republic
not quite a democracy that was actually
part of the vision of what set this
nation into Motion in the first place is
direct democracy especially diverse
diverse direct democracy doesn't work
now before the basic principle behind
this idea was you have to have skin in
the game in order to play in that game
including as a citizen it used to be as
a landowner that era has passed I mean
uh for now maybe bring it back well so
so so here's so here's where I'm going
with it okay let's let's not bring the
landowner thing back
what about Civic service service
guaranteeing citizenship
basically and also as a condition for
all of the of the Privileges of
citizenship I think that would solve a
lot I think it goes a long way so you
get these privileges and immunities of
citizenship in the 14th amendment in
this proposal okay the immunities
everyone gets that is the government
can't knock on your door search your
house without a warrant can't Muzzle you
from speaking those are the immunities
but the Privileges tax deductions all
the way up to and including voting you
only get if you serve that nation in
common cause black white
red blue gay straight doesn't matter yep
if you want to vote that's your skin in
the game you serve the country that
creates that that satisfies that
National purpose the americanism that
satisfies that hunger for purpose of
meaning if you don't vote you don't have
to vote but if you want to vote earn it
and the service could be and you guys
are into it I thought you were all gone
yeah
service guarantees okay not just
military but it could also be any type
of Public Service
Capital citizenship lowercase
citizenship you still get all the
benefits and privileges it's not a surf
class millions and citizens civilians
and Citizens Capital Citizens
Service could include you know having
squads of people going around to make
sure that everyone uh you know bends the
knee to Black lives matter making sure
that we have putting up political
slogans uh all over you know so you
can't Define it you can't Define it that
could be Public Service you can't I
agree that's my main problem with that
actually I can't Define it too
squishially but I see the government
abusing that power essentially in so
many different ways but we could talk
about it in an after show too because
this is a great discussion then let me
do just one one last Super Chat before
we Bounce from Steve Robertson Luke did
we land on the Moon why or why not I
don't know I don't have all the answers
here oh I'm skeptical
my original thought is
um you know there's a lot of uh bullcrap
out there and my you know I know he's
saying no I didn't do much research into
it but my gut instinct is they probably
lied let's talk about service
guaranteeing citizenship in the members
only section I actually have some
philosophical questions for you as well
about when the government should
intervene in medical care for kids so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com
because we're going to have that members
only show coming up for you we usually
post it about an hour or so from now so
you don't want to miss it you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me at Tim timcast on Twitter or wherever
else maybe not Twitter for long who
knows Vivek do you want to shout
anything out
thanks guys good conversation I mean I
think you know Market Solutions not all
Government Solutions strive.com if you
want to learn more about strive but more
importantly educate yourself Empower
yourself that's the path forward right
on uh you can follow me at the Lauren
Chen Instagram Twitter telegram Lauren
Chen on YouTube as well as mediaholic
for that entertainment stuff and you
know if you want to buy something to
support me again that is etsy.com shop
slash clearly pure Naturals
c-l-e-a-r-l-y-p-u-r Naturals uh we've
got soaps beard bombs body butters beard
oils gift baskets free shipping in the
US over 35 this was great
um I thought this conversation went
really deep and thank you guys for for
doing that it was really really a great
conversation uh my website is
lukeansensor.com I did a video there for
my members about gut health and diet I
went also uh talked about a lot of
nuance issues that I think are very
important for people to find out since
uh
we're being poisoned in many different
ways oh we should have talked about seed
oils oh my goodness don't get me started
look uncensor.com my website I'm going
to be there for that conversation and I
think someone also has a book here that
hasn't uh promoted it yet well I want to
ever read the book uh if they if they
haven't read it already woke ink was my
first one came out uh last last August
and this September just came out the
sequel to woke Inc which is nation of
victims so check it out let me know what
you think
and I want to give a special thanks to
Charlie Kirk because we're in his studio
and they are drinking his water drinking
and metal it's in metal you know I've
probably lined with plastic well he's a
healthy guy so uh you know as we're out
here TP USA has uh has helped us out
following amfest to be able to keep
doing the show and we're grateful so
thank you all so much and we will see
you all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging up